हेलो एवरीवन एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
एंड सबसे पहले मुझे बता दीजिए सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर
एवरीवन लाउड एंड क्लियर
टुडे देर इज ओनली 30
स्टूडेंट दिस इज वेरी बैड फॉर मी
दे ओनली
29 आप लोग बताइए मैं क्या
करूं सेशन डिले होने का कारण यह है कि मैं
थोड़ा सा बिजी था और मे बी नेक्स्ट सेशन
भी थोड़ा सा डिले हो जाए मेरे बिजी रूटीन
की वजह से मतलब मैं थोड़ा सा बिजी हूं
कहीं पर बाहर चला गया था तो मैं अवेलेबल
नहीं था और ऊपर से आपका जो कंटेंट है उसको
रेडी करने के लिए भी मुझे थोड़ा सा टाइम
चाहिए होता है बेसिकली आपके पीपीटी
प्रेजेंटेशन रेडी करने के लिए कि किस डीप
में किस डीप नॉलेज के साथ आपको पढ़ाना है
वो सारी चीज के लिए इसलिए थोड़ा सा टाइम
लगता है बट हमेशा ट्राई करता हूं कि जितना
जल्दी हो सकू उतना जल्दी आपके सामने सेशन
लेकर आऊ मैं आप लोगों को जानबूझ के डिलीट
नहीं डिले नहीं करना चाहता और मे भी आप
लोगों के लिए बेनिफिट हो क्योंकि आप
स्टूडेंट भी हो सकते हैं और वर्किंग
प्रोफेशनल भी हो सकते तो सेशन इस टाइमिंग
पर सही
रहेगा नहीं 2 के फ क मेरे लिए तो बहुत कम
है ना मेरी जो सेशन डिलीवरी के हिसाब से
तो बहुत कम है आप लोगों के लिए ज्यादा
होंगे मे बहुत कम
है चलो सेशन स्टार्ट करेंगे देखिए मुझे
पता है कि आज के सेशन में जो भी कुछ हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं और अगले आने वाले कुछ सेशन
में हम जो कुछ पढ़ने वाले हैं हो सकता है
आप लोगों को पहले से पता हो आप लोगों को
लगता है कि मुझे पता है इसलिए मैं सेशन
अटेंड करके क्या करूंगा वेस्टिंग ऑफ माय
टाइम बट बिलीव मी कि आपका टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
होगा इसके तीन चार कारण है पहला कारण तो
यह है कि आपका रिवीजन हो जाएगा उस चीज के
बारे में दूसरा कारण क्या होगा कि हो सकता
है कुछ चीज आपसे छूट गई होगी या कुछ चीज
बताते वक्त आपके इंस्ट्रक्टर ने छोड़ दिया
होगा उससे बाय मिस्टेक रह गई होगी तो आपके
लिए कुछ नई चीज आपको सीखने को मिल सकती है
थर्ड कांसेप्ट क्लियर अगर कोई पहले से
डाउट रहा होगा तो फिर से आप डाउट पूछ सकते
हो और अपना डाउट क्लियर कर सकते हो फोर्थ
पॉइंट ये है कि मेरे जितने भी सेशंस
अपकमिंग सेशंस होंगे जितने भी अभी आज के
बाद सारे इंटरडिपेंडेंट है मतलब एक सेशन
के ऊपर दूसरा दूसरा सेशन डिपेंड करेगा कुछ
सेशन हो गया आप डायरेक्टली जवाइन कर सकते
हो जिनके पास थोड़ी बहुत नॉलेज होगी बट
विश्वास कीजिए कि मैं जो आपको पढ़ाने वाला
हूं ना जिस तरीके से मैं आपको बताने वाला
हूं कि मैं आपको एक ऐसे वे में लेकर
जाऊंगा कि कभी भी आपको कहीं से भी
खास कर के बिगनर लेवल का जो एथिकल हैकिंग
कोर्सेस
होगा वह आपको कोई नहीं पढ़ा सकता इवन आप
50 टू 60000 पे करोगे एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स
के लिए बेसिक बिगनर टू चाहे एडवांस हो या
बिगनर टू इंटरमीडिएट
हो जिस तरीके से मैं आपको आज डिलीवर
करूंगा आने वाले सेशन और आज का
सेशन मे बी मैंने तो नहीं होते हुए डिलीवर
डिलीवर होते हुए देखा सेशन को अगर आप
लोगों ने देखा होगा तो आई कांट से बट मुझे
नहीं लगता कोई इस तरीके से सेशन को डिलीवर
करेगा कि इस तरीके से आपको एक वे में लेकर
जाएगा कि आपका फंडामेंटल क्लियर प्लस में
आपका एक प्रोफेशनल नॉलेज भी आपको अच्छी
खासी होगी तो डोंट वरी जो लोग सेशन मिस कर
रहे हैं
तो अच्छी बात है जो अटेंड कर ले हैं उनके
लिए ज्यादा अच्छी बात है बट मैं आप लोगों
को यही बात बोलूंगा अटेंड कीजिए अटेंड
करने में हो सकता है कि आप कुछ चीज उस
टाइम पर मिस कर गए होंगे इसलिए मैं
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि आज से जो सेशन हो
रहे हैं जितने भी प्लीज उनको मिस मत कीजिए
मिस करोगे आप लोगों का खुद का पर्सनल लॉस
होगा मेरा कोई लॉस नहीं उसमें मेरे को
डिलीवर करना मैं डिलीवर करूंगा हां थोड़ा
सा लस य कि मैं डी मोटिवेट होगा आप लोगों
के रिस्पांस कम आने की वजह से ओके
तो देखिए आज हम एंटर करने वाले हैं सेक्शन
टू एक्टिव इनफ
गैदरिंग जो सबसे मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट स्टेप है किसी भी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग फेज के लिए जब आपके पास एक
इंफॉर्मेशन हो जाए पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग कर लोगे जब आपके पास कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन है तो फिर आप उसके साथ क्या
करते हो एक्टिवली
इंगेज इंगेज होते हो और एक्टिवली इंगेज
होने के बाद आप क्या करते हो उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को फर्द रिकॉन करते हो फरदर उस
परे एंसिस करते हो कि मुझे और क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल सकती है तो सेकंड सेक्शन
हमारा स्टार्ट हो चुका है एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग ओके तो नेक्स्ट चलते
हैं डाउट बोर्ड तो मैंने शायद डे थ्री की
क्लास में मैंने आपको बताया था अगर आप
लोगों को को कोई भी डाउट्स है मेरे किसी
भी सेशन में तो आप
[संगीत]
तो
अवेलेबल रहती
youtube0 मेरा डाउट था प्लीज क्लियर कर
दीजिए अगर वह आपका डाउट ऐसा होगा कि मैं
मैसेज के थ्रू आपको सेम टाइम क्लियर कर
सकता तो आपको रिप्लाई में डाउट क्लियर हो
जाएगा अगर वह डाउट ऐसा होगा कि नेक्स्ट डे
की नेक्स्ट डे की जो क्लास होगी नेक्स्ट
क्लास होगी उसमें अगर क्लियर करना है तो
उसमें मैं आपका क्लियर कर दूंगा थर्ड अगर
आपका वो डाउट होगा कि अपकमिंग क्लास में
उस डाउट को हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं तो उस
डाउट को मैं क्या करूंगा यह रहा डाउट
बोर्ड है आप लोगों के सामने एक डाउट बोर्ड
है एक डाउट बोर्ड पर तब तक हाईलाइट करके
रखूंगा जब तक उस डाउट को मैं क्लियर ना कर
दूं और जिसका जो डाउट क्लियर हो जाएगा इस
बोर्ड से हम उसको क्या कर देंगे रिमूव कर
देंगे सो दैट कि इन फ्यूचर कभी भी किसी को
लगता कि वो डाउट आया होगा तो उनका डाउट
क्लियर हो जाएगा तो मैंने एक एक पहल की है
एक अच्छा तरीका
अ तरीके से हम यूज करें ना कि बैड तरीके
से तो आप लोगों को मैंने बता दिया कि आप
कैसे डाउट पूछ सकते हो तो अभी तक प्रीवियस
क्लासेस लेटेड आपको कोई भी डाउट नहीं है
इसलिए यहां पर नील है अगर आपके डाउट्स
होंगे नील की जगह आपके डाउट्स रहेंगे कि
आपका डाउट एक्चुअल में क्या था उस डाउट पर
हम डिस्कशन करेंगे चाहे नेक्स्ट क्लास में
करें या उससे कुछ सेशन के बाद डिस्कस करें
लेकिन वो डाउट डिस्कस 100% होगा उस डाउट
को तब तक हम बोर्ड से रिमूव नहीं करेंगे
तब तक वो डाउट्स डिस्कस नहीं होगा ओके तो
तो चलिए हम सेशन स्टार्ट
करें ऑलरेडी 10 मिनट हो चुकी है और देर 49
स्टूडेंट्स
तो स्टार्ट करें
तो सर अभी हम उस परे डिस्कस नहीं कर सकते
पहले इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट कीजिए और फिर ट
की कुछ पॉलिसी के देख के ही हम उस परे
डिस्कशन कर सकते हैं क्योंकि आप मलिस भी
यूज कर लोगे तो डायरेक्टली नाम और ब्लेम
मुझ भी आ
जाएगा चलो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं तो स्टार्ट
करने से पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता
हूं कि आपको क्या करना है कि अभी कुछ टाइम
के लिए म जो भी कांसेप्ट पढ़ा रहा हूं उस
कांसेप्ट में अगर आपका कोई भी डाउट्स आता
है तो प्लीज उस डाउट्स को चैट सेक्शन में
तब तक ना ना डालिए तब तक ये सेशन के लास्ट
एंड तक हम ना पहुंच जाए मतलब कि सेशन खत्म
करने वाले ना हो जाए क्योंकि इसका एक कारण
है क्योंकि मैं जो आपके सामने डिलीवर करने
वाला हूं उस सेशन के मुझे पता है कि
स्टार्टिंग में थोड़ा सा बोरिंग लगेगा कुछ
डाउट्स भी आएंगे आपको समझ में भी नहीं
आएगा लेकिन आई प्रॉमिस एंड ऑफ द
सेशन आपके बिना डाउट लिए ही मैं आपके डाउट
क्लियर कर दूंगा क्योंकि जो डाउट्स आपके
दिमाग में आ सकता है उस डाउट को सोच के
मैं पीपीटी तैयार की है और उसका आंसर में
ऑटोमेटिक दे दूंगा तो आपको डाउट मैसेज में
टाइप करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी फिर भी
आपके कोई डाउट्स है तो फिर आप क्या कर
सकते हो लास्ट में आप पूछ सकते हो या आप
जो अभी मैंने थोड़ी देर पहले बताया आप
मैसेज कर सकते हो
ऑन एन इंटरनल नेटवर्क ऑफ ए कंपनी कोई भी
कंपनी है उसके इंटरनल नेटवर्क प आप क्या
कर रहे हो एक पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म
कर रहे हो एथिकल हैकिंग कर रहे हो विद
प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन तो ड्यूरिंग इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग यू हैव एन आइडिया ऑफ नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर ऑफ ए कंपनी जब आपने पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की थी उस टाइम पर आपके
पास कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन थी उस कंपनी की जिससे
आपने एक रफ आईडिया लगाया था कि इस कंपनी
का कंपनी का नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर यह
हो सकता है मतलब वहां पर आईपी एड्रेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली आपको सबनेट की इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली जिससे आपने आईपी एड्रेस के आधार पर
यह पता लगाया कि ओके इस टाइप की नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर हो सकती है ओके देन जब
आपके पास ये इंफॉर्मेशन है डोमेन नेम है
या आईपी एड्रेस है ओके तो देन व्हाट विल
बी योर ऑब्जेक्टिव आपका नेक्स्ट
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या होगा टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
फम दैट पॉइंट यू मूव ऑन टू परफॉर्म ए
पोर्ट स्कैन ऑन दज एक्टिव होस्ट एंड ट्राई
टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एंड सर्विसिंग रनिंग ऑन द ओपन पोर्ट्स एटस
बेसिकली अग अगला मेरा ऑब्जेक्टिव ये होगा
कि उस आईपी एड्रेस के ऊपर या उस नेटवर्क
के ऊपर मैं ये आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एक्टिव है यह यह मतलब यह होस्ट एक्टिव है
अलाइव है तो उसके ऊपर मैं क्या करूंगा फिर
मैं पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करूंगा मैं एक्टिव
होस्ट के पर पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करूंगा यह पता
लगाने की कोशिश करूंगा कि उस पोर्ट
कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स एक्टिव है और किस
पोर्ट्स पर कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रही है और
साथ के साथ यह भी पता लगाने की कोशिश
करूंगा कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑपरेट
हो रहा है उस होस्ट के ऊपर नाउ तो देन
फर्स्ट ऑफ ल वी नीड टू लर्न हाउ टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन व्ट होस्ट आर एक्टिव ऑन ए
नेटवर्क एंड फ्रॉम दैट पॉइंट वी नीड टू
लर्न हाउ टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
में दे आर रनिंग तो सबसे पहले हम ये
सीखेंगे कि अपनी एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में कि उस नेटवर्क के ऊपर कौन से
होस्ट एक्टिव है उसके बाद हम पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग करेंगे सर्विसेस फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करेंगे और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करेंगे थ्रू एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग चलो
नेक्स्ट इस जो सेक्शन में जो एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग सेक्शन है सेक्शन टू
है इसमें जो बेसिक आपका जो ऑब्जेक्टिव
रहेगा जो आपके मेन मेन टॉपिक्स रहेंगे जो
आप पूरे सेक्शन में कवर करने वाले हो वेरी
डीप वो है आपके नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स क्यों
इसका एक कान रहेगा जब यह सेक्शन कंप्लीट
कर लोगे या कुछ टाइम बाद जब किसी भी
इंटरव्यू में बैठोगे या आप जब एथिकल
हैकिंग परफॉर्म करोगे तब आपको पता चलेगा
कि आपका नेटवर्क फंडा टल्स मैंने क्यों
पढ़ाया था इसलिए नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल काफी
जरूरी है इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के दौरान ओके
देन उसके बाद की जो होस्ट है उनकी नेटवर्क
मैपिंग कैसे करते हैं सेकंड टॉपिक हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं देन होस्ट डिस्कवरी पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग फिर उसके बाद होस्ट की
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग जहां पर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन हमें मिलेगी देन उसके
बाद हम एन मैप की जो स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन है
उसके बारे में इंट्रोडक्शन करें क्योंकि
बेसिकली वो सारी चीज हम ए मैप के थ्रू ही
करने वाले हैं मोस्ट फोकस टूल रहेगा हमारा
उसके बाद फायर वल डिटेक्शन एंड इजन और जो
स्कैन की जो टाइमिंग है उसके परफॉर्मेंस
को कैसे हम और बेटर तरीके से यूज कर सकते
हैं तो दिस इज द ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ योर होल
सेक्शन मे बी इसके लिए आपको अगर 10 सेशन
लग जाए मे भी हो सकता कि 10 सेशन और
डिलीवर हो जाए तो नो प्रॉब्लम आई विल
डिलीवर बट आई विल कवर कंप्लीट इन डिटेल्स
नाउ तो मोस्ट प्रेफरड टूल रहेगा इस सेक्शन
के दौरान हमारा एन मैप एक कारण है क्योंकि
देखो वैसे तो मार्केट में बहुत सारे
स्कैनिंग टूल्स पोर्ट स्कैनर होट डिस्कवरी
टूल्स आर अवेलेबल बट क्या है कि एन मैप
यूज करने के कुछ कारस हैं ओके सबसे पहली
बात तो एक टेस्टेड है यहां पर फाल्स
नेगेटिव या बोल सकते हैं कि यहां पर गलत
रिजल्ट आने के वेर रेयर चांसेस ज्यादा
चांसेस नहीं है ओके नाउ ऊपर से सबसे
ज्यादा यूज किया जाने वाला टूल है पेन
टेस्टर के द्वारा रेड टी मर्स के द्वारा
या आपके नेटवर्क इंजीनियर के द्वारा ठीक
है और इंस्ट्रिंग में भी इसको काफी चाहे
वो ऑफेंसिव हो चाहे डिफेंस साइड हो दोनों
साइड इसको क्या है सबसे ज्यादा यूज किया
जाता है तो हमारा मोस्ट फोकस जो टूल रहेगा
ए मैप रहेगा और ए मैप को इतना डिटेल्स में
मैं आपको पढ़ाऊंगा कि आप ए मैप को बाय गॉड
अपने सिनेरियो के अकॉर्डिंग उस ए मैप को
बिना किसी चीट सीट के यूज कर पाओगे एन मैप
को हम बहुत डीट में डिटेल्स में पढ़ने
वाले हैं इसके बाद आपको कहीं से भी एन मैप
पढ़ने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी चाहे वो
नाउ उसके बाद हम बात करते हैं एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की कि ये एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग होता क्या है ओके तो
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इज द फेज ऑफ
असेसमेंट
वेयर ऑल अटैकर्स पन टेस्टर्स और एथिकल
हैकर्स एक्टिवली इंटरेक्ट विद द टारगेट
सिस्टम और नेटवर्क टू कलेक्ट डाटा एंड टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
गैदरिंग के दौरान
आप किसी भी टारगेट के साथ एक्टिवली इंगेज
करते हो ओके विद प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन प्रॉपर
परमिशन अब जब आप किसी भी टारगेट के साथ
एक्टिवली इंगेज करते हो तो वहां पर आप
क्या करते हो स्कैनिंग करते हो प्रोबिन
करते हो डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्ट करते हो
नेटवर्क सर्विसेस के साथ साथ और यह पता
लगाने की कोशिश करते हो कि उसके ऊपर कौन
से होस्ट अलाइव है एक्टिव है कौन सी
सर्विस रनिंग है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या है उसके बाद फर्द उसके
अंदर हम क्या करते हैं एनमने करते हैं
फर्द वलन बिटीज को फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं कि पहले से कोई वलने
बिलिटी इसमें एजिस्ट करती है या नहीं है
नाउ उसके बाद अभी तक हमने जो पढ़ा
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के अंदर हमें पता है
कि पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग और एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हम कर
चुके हैं कुछ टूल्स हमारे बचे हुए हैं तो
उनको मैं लास्ट में कवर कर दूंगा इसलिए
मैं लेकिन अब मैं क्या कर एक मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट सेक्शन स्टार्ट करना चाहता था
इसलिए मैंने इंपॉर्टेंट सेक्शन स्टार्ट
किया है देन एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के
हम में अभी जबसे फोकस करेंगे स्कैनिंग के
ऊपर देन उसके बाद जो थर्ड सेक्शन होगा
हमारा नमरे रहेगा और मेनली हम जो फोकस
करेंगे वो होस्ट डिस्कवरी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
और ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फिंगरप्रिंटिंग के
ऊपर बात करेंगे देन हम एन्यूमरेशन को भी
वेरी डीप वेरी प्रेसा इजली उसके लिए जो हर
एक छोटी सी छोटी इंफॉर्मेशन जो मुझे कवर
करनी होगी फंडामेंटल से लेके एक टूल तक हर
एक चीज में चाहे वो थोट चाहे प्रैक्टिकल
दोनों के दोनों में एक तरीके से एक सेंस
से आपके सामने रखूंगा सो दैट कि आपको वो
चीजें बिल्कुल क्लियर हो जाए दोबारा कहीं
से आपको पढ़ने की जरूरत ना पड़े ये पीपीटी
आपको मिल जाएगी और एक और चीज है कि मेरे
हमारे जो
वहां पर अगर सर्च करके देखोगे उस पर क्लिक
करोगे तो वहां पर मैंने ऑलरेडी जो अभी तक
जितने भी सेशंस हुए हैं सेशन रिलेटेड
उसमें क्या पढ़ाया क्या नहीं पढ़ाया उससे
रिलेटेड सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मेंशन किया है
विद जो भी नोट्स उसके अवेलेबल थे इवन अभी
तक के सारे नोट्स मैं शेयर कर चुका हूं
नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं सबसे पहले
नेटवर्किंग फंडामेंटल्स के बारे में
क्योंकि सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
हमारे लिए कि नेटवर्किंग फंडामेंटल्स में
भी नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स देखिए द प्राइमरी
गोल ऑफ नेटवर्किंग इज एक्सचेंज ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन
बिटवीन नेटवर्क कंप्यूटर्स और कंप्यूटर्स
दैट आर कनेक्टेड टू ईच अदर वाया ए नेटवर्क
सबसे प्राइमरी गोल क्या है नेटवर्किंग का
इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सचेंज ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन व्हाट
एवर मीडियम मतलब कोई भी चाहे व नेटवर्क
कंप्यूटर हो या दोनों कंप्यूटर आपस से
कनेक्टेड है लेकिन उनका मीडियम क्या होना
चाहिए नेटवर्क ना इन ऑर्डर फॉर दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन टू बी ट्रांसफर्ड देयर नीड टू
बी बी ए स्टैंडर्डाइज फॉर्मेट अभी दो
कंप्यूटर्स को या दो डिवाइसेज को इंटरेक्ट
करने के लिए इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर करने के लिए
एक स्टैंडर्डाइज फॉर्मेट की जरूरत थी ओके
एंड इन कंप्यूटर
नेटवर्क्स इन कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क्स होस्ट
कम्युनिकेट विद ईच अदर थ्रू द यूज ऑफ
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल अ जो होस्ट होते हैं
मैं बार-बार आपके सामने होस्ट बोल रहा हूं
कि होस्ट होता क्या है ओके ये होस्ट होता
क्या है होस्ट होता है
आपका सिस्टम आपके कंप्यूटर जो नेटवर्क से
कनेक्टेड है आपके डिवाइस आपके लैपटॉप्स
आपके स्मार्टफोन आपके आईओटी डिवाइस ये
सारे सारे किसके अंदर आते हैं होस्ट के
अंदर आते हैं ओके तो नाउ अभी जो यह
कम्युनिकेट करते हैं एक दूसरे के साथ वह
किसके थ्रू करते हैं नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स
के थ्रू ओके नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स नाउ
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या होता है देखो
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स इंश्योर दैट डिफरेंट
क क्यूटर सिस्टम यूजिंग डिफरेंट हार्डवेयर
एंड सॉफ्टवेयर कैन कम्युनिकेट वि विद ईच
अदर अब नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल की हेल्प से कोई
भी कंप्यूटर है चाहे उसका कोई भी
हार्डवेयर है किसी टाइप का सॉफ्टवेयर है
वो एक दूसरे के साथ क्या कर सकता है
कम्युनिकेट कर सकते हैं यह क्या करता है
एक स्टैंडर्डाइज क्रिएट करता है इन फॉर्म
ऑफ अ फॉर्म ऑफ कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन द टू
सिस्टम दो सिस्टम के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन
करने का स्टैंडर्डाइज एक फॉर्मेट क्रिएट
करता है स्टैंडर्डाइज है यह एवरीवन नोज
दैट देयर आर ए लार्ज नंबर ऑफ नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स दैट आर यूज्ड बाय डिफरेंट
सर्विसेस टू अचीव डिफरेंट ऑब्जेक्टिव और
फंक्शनल और टू ट्रांसफर डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन यह आप सबको पता है कि मार्केट
में या जो हम भी नेटवर्क यूज करते हैं
उसमें डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टाइप्स के नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज होते हैं जो अवेलेबल है
एसटीटीपी एचटीटीपीएस डीएनएस डीएससीपी आईपी
एड्रेस हो गया या आपका अ एफटीपी हो गया
टेलनेट हो गया एसएमटीपी हो गया आपका नेट
बायस हो
गया एसएमबी हो गया दे लॉट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल्स
आर अवेलेबल जो हर एक की अपनी एक फंक्शन
होती है हर एक का अपना काम होता है जिसकी
हेल्प से क्या करते है हम इंफॉर्मेशन
एक्सचेंज करते हैं एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस के साथ ओके नाउ नेक्स्ट
कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन डिफरेंट होस्ट वाय
प्रोटोकॉल इज फैसिलिटेटेड थ्रू द यूज ऑफ
पैकेट अ जो कम्युनिकेशन होता है डिफरेंट
फ्रेंट होस्ट के बीच में उन वो होता है
पैकेट के द्वारा अब ये पैकेट्स क्या होते
हैं पैकेट किस टाइप्स का दिखता है और
पैकेट्स का हम अपने टूल्स में किस तरीके
से यूज करते हैं यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन जानने
से पहले हमें सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
के बारे में पढ़ना होता है जो आप सबको पता
है पहले से ही पता है कि जब भी हम
नेटवर्किंग की बात करते हैं तो हम एक
टॉपिक के बारे में पढ़ते हैं जिसका नाम है
ओ एसआई मॉडल ठीक है जिसका नाम क्या है ओ
एसआई मॉडल ओपन सिस्टम इंटरकनेक्शन जिसने
पूरे के पूरे नेटवर्क को सेवन लेयर में
डिसाइड डिवाइड कर दिया ताकि पूरा जो
नेटवर्किंग है नेटवर्किंग उसको हम समझ सके
ओके तो अभी तक किसी का कोई डाउट है
[संगीत]
आर्यन ओके तो आर्यन अगर आप लिंकडन चलाते
हो तो आप एक काम करो लिंकन में आप डे
फोनिक्स अकेडमी पर जाइए वहां पर मेरी एक
प्रोफाइल होगी सम नाम से एस ए एम एस एच ए
एम ओके वहां पर जाकर मुझको मैसेज कर दीजिए
मैं आपको कांटेक्ट कर लूंगा और आपकी हेल्प
कर दूंगा कि काली नेस को कैसे इंस्टॉल
करना ओके मैं इतना कर सकता हूं आपके
लिए किसी को कोई डाउट है अभी हम ओ एसआई
मॉडल स्टार्ट करेंगे अगले एक घंटे या डेढ़
घंटे में मैं आज थोड़ा सा ज्यादा चल सकता
क्योंकि ओआई मॉडल को आज नेटवर्किंग
फंडामेंटल की तरफ से क्लियर करना है
नेक्स्ट क्लास क्लास में हम साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वस से भी बताएंगे कि ओ एसआई
लेयर पर कौन-कौन से अटैक होते हैं तो
इसलिए पहले हम इसका फंडामेंटल जानेंगे और
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम यह जानेंगे कि एज अ
साइबर सिक्योरिटी वे कि कौन-कौन से अटैक
कौन-कौन सी लेयर पे काम करते
हैं चलो हम बात कर रहे हैं अभी ओ एसआई
मॉडल क्या होता है देखो ओपन सिस्टम
इंटरकनेक्शन मॉडल इज ए कांसेप्चुअल
फ्रेमवर्क यूज टू अंडरस्टैंड एंड
स्टैंडर्डाइज द फंक्शन ऑफ नेटवर्क और
कम्युनिकेशन सिस्टम ओके बेसिकली वी कैन से
दैट इट इज ए रेफरेंस मॉडल जब भी हम बात
करते हैं नेटवर्किंग में नेटवर्क को अगर
हमें जानना है चाहे वो नेटवर्क इंजीनियर
हो चाहे वो साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर हो
तो सबसे पहले हमें ओसल मॉडल पढ़ाया जाता
है क्योंकि एक ये
थोरेट्स इंप्लीमेंट कौन सा होता है टीसीपी
आईपी ओके नाउ इट इज इट डिवाइड्स द एंटायस
प्रोसेस और एंटायस इनटू सेवन डिस्टिंक्ट
लेयर इसने पूरे पूरे जो जो कम्युनिकेशन
प्रोसेस थी उसको सात अलग-अलग लेयर में
क्या कर दिया डिवाइड कर दिया ओके नाउ ईच
लेयर ऑफ द ओआई मॉडल परफॉर्म ए स्पेसिफिक
सेट ऑफ टास्क रिलेटेड टू नेटवर्क
कम्युनिकेशन हेल्पिंग स्टैंडर्डाइज हाउ
डेटा इज ट्रांसमिटेड एंड रिसीवड अक्रॉस
डिफरेंट डिवाइसेज एंड नेटवर्क ओके
ओबवियसली हर एक लेयर का अपना एक काम है और
हर एक लेयर एक दूसरे के ऊपर डिपेंड करती
है इंटरडिपेंडेंट है ये नहीं कि हर एक
लेयर का अपना काम तो वो अपने तरीके से काम
करी नहीं हर एक लेयर सारी की सेवन की जो
जितनी भी सेवन लेयर्स है वो सारी की सारी
क्या करती हैं एक दूसरे के ऊपर डिपेंड
करती हैं ओके अभी जब ओ एसआई मॉडल नहीं आया
था उससे पहले क्या होता था कि सबसे बड़ी
जो चैलेंज था कि एक कंपनी दूसरी कंपनी के
साथ या एक डिवाइस दूसरी डिवाइस के साथ
क्या था कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर पा रहा था खास
कर के डिफरेंट डिफरेंट कंपनीज क्योंकि
सबके अपने प्रोटोकॉल थे लेकिन जब बात आती
थी कि एक कंपनी को दूसरे कंपनी के साथ
डाटा शेयर करना है तो वह नहीं कर पाते थे
तो उस केस में 19 एगजैक्टली आई डोंट नो कि
68 के आसपास दिस मॉडल कम्स टीसीपीआईपी और
ओ एसआई मॉडल य थोट मॉडल रेडी हुआ था
टीसीईपी प्रैक्टिकल मॉडल था तभी आया था
मार्केट में उसके बाद से आप देख सकते हो
कि यह हर जगह यूज होता है पूरा नेटवर्क यह
ओआई मॉडल से ही चलता है तो व्हाई इज द ओ
एसआई मॉडल इंपॉर्टेंट सबसे पहली बा पहला
कारण है स्टैंडर्डाइजेशन द ओई मॉडल
प्रोवाइड्स ए स्टैंडर्डाइज फ्रेमवर्क दैट
इंश्योर डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ नेटवर्क्स
टोपोलॉजी ना टेक्नोलॉजीज एंड डिवाइसेज कैन
वर्क टुगेदर ओके इट डिफाइंस द फंक्शंस ऑफ
ईच लेयर इनेबलिंग डिवाइस फ्रॉम डिफरेंट
मैन्युफैक्चरर टू कम्युनिकेट विद ईच अदर
सेल्फ एक्सप्लेनेटरी है मुझे इसमें हिंदी
में कुछ भी क्लियर कर कवर करने की जरूरत
नहीं है नाउ सेकंड कारण क्या था ट्रबल
शूटिंग बाय सेपरेटिंग नेटवर्क कम्युनिकेशन
इनटू लेव लेयर्स द ओआई मॉडल मेक्स इट
इजियर टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
हो सकती है ले में प्रॉब्लम हो सकती या
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर की प्रॉब्लम हो सकती है
मतलब डाटा ट्रांसफर हो रहा तब प्रॉब्लम हो
रही है या आपके फिजिकल लेयर इन आपके
इंटरफेस में प्रॉब्लम है या आपके जो केबल
में प्रॉब्लम है या आपका जो ट्रांसफर हो
डाटा वो एरर कर रहा है किसी भी का तो सारी
चीजें क्या है ट्रबल शूट करना काफी इजी हो
गया ओ एसआई मॉडल की हेल्प से ओके नाउ
डिजाइन एंड
डेवलपमेंट इट आल्सो डेवलपर टू फोकस ऑन
स्पेसिफिक लेयर फंक्शनल ड्यूरिंग द
डेवलपमेंट ऑफ नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स मेकिंग
इयर टू क्रिएट सॉफ्टवेयर एंड हार्डवेयर ट
वर्क सीमलेसली विद अदर डिवाइस इन द
नेटवर्क ओबवियसली क्योंकि जब भी कोई अभी
कोई भी डेवलपर है कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर क्रिएट
करता है खासकर कौन सा नेटवर्क बग
सॉफ्टवेयर है जब भी सॉफ्टवेयर हार्डवेयर
क्रिएट करता तो व इन सातों लेयर को ध्यान
में रखते हुए उसको डिफाइन करता है ताकि वह
अच्छे से स्पोर्ट करे और यूज में आ सके
नाउ दे टोटल सेवन लेयर्स हम बात कर सबसे
पहले क्या फिजिकल लेयर डेटा लिंक लेयर
नेटवर्क लेयर ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सेशन लेयर
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर एंड एप्लीकेशन दे आर
टोटल टोटल सेवन लेयर्स ओके सबसे टॉप अपर
मोस्ट लेयर कौन सी आपकी सेशन अ एप्लीकेशन
लेयर एंड सबसे जो लोअर मोस्ट जो लेयर आपकी
फिजिकल लेयर है नेक्स्ट अब कंपैरिजन करते
हैं टीसीपीआई अभी जो बात करते ओआई मॉडल
क्या सेवन लेयर में डिवाइडेड है लेकिन
टीसीपीआईपी ओरिजिनल पहले चार लेयर में
डिवाइडेड था एप्लीकेशन ले कॉमिनेशन ऑफ दज
एप्लीकेशन लेयर प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर एंड सेशन
लेयर ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर एज इट इज नेटवर्क
लेयर एज इट इज और जो आपके डेटा लिंक लेयर
थी और फिजिकल लेयर लिंक लेयर की तरह
कहलाती थी नाउ नाउ एडेज टीसीपी आईपी
अपडेटेड है अभी टीसीपी आईपी को हम बोलते
हैं फाइव लेयर्स हैं एप्लीकेशन लेयर एज इट
इज ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर नेटवर्क लेयर डेटा
लिंक लेयर एंड फिजिकल लेयर ओके ये एक
प्रैक्टिकल मॉडल है लेकिन ये एक यह क्या
है आपका रेफरेंस मॉडल है एक थरेट कल मॉडल
है जब भी हम अ टीसीपीआईपी प्रैक्टिकल मॉडल
को समझने के लिए हमें ओ एसआई मॉडल को
पढ़ना ही पड़ेगा तभी हमें टीसीपीआईपी
प्रैक्टिकल मॉडल समझ में आएगा तो इसलिए
मेरा पढ़ाने का मोटो या कोई भी आपको
पढ़ाता तो ओ एसआई मॉडल ही पढ़ाता है
टीसीपीआई प आपको प्रैक्टिकली पढ़ाया जाता
है
ओके ओके दे
एक है हमारे ग्रुप में बोल रहे हैं कि अम
ब्लो सर इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में ओ एसआई
मॉडल का क्या
काम तो मे भी आप तो इतने बड़े हैकर होंगे
कि शायद आप हमें सिखा रहे हैं तो मैं आपको
कमेंट नहीं करूंगा बट जिनको देखना कि ओ
एसआई मॉडल का क्या काम है और ओ एसआई मॉडल
हम क्यों सीख रहे हैं तो अपकमिंग सेशन में
देख लीजिए अगर आपको कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
तो यू कैन लीव ना मेरे को भी आपको कोई
इंटरेस्ट नहीं है पढ़ाने में
नाउ अभी बात करते हैं कि ओआई मॉडल के बारे
में पढ़ने वाले हैं कि एक कंप्यूटर से
दूसरे कंप्यूटर में कैसे डाटा फ्लो करता
है कैसे डाटा को प्रिपेयर और ट्रांसमिट
किया जाता है और जितनी भी सेवन लेयर्स है
इसके बारे में डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन लेने वाले
हैं ओके हम इसको डिटेल्स में पढ़ने वाले
हैं ओके नाउ सबसे पहली जो लेयर
है जो सबसे पहली लेयर है जो आपकी सब सबसे
टॉप मोस्ट लेयर है अपर मोस्ट लेयर है वो
आपकी एप्लीकेशन लेयर द एप्लीकेशन लेयर इज
द सेवंथ एंड टॉप मोस्ट लेयर ऑफ द ओआई मॉडल
ओके दिस लेयर इज द इंटरफेस बिटवीन द एंड
यूजर एप्लीकेशन एंड द अंडरलाइन नेटवर्क सो
दैट सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन कैन कम्युनिकेट
विद ईच अदर ओवर ए नेटवर्क बेसिकली क्या
होता है एंड यूजर्स कौन है हम लोग जो
ह्यूमन बीइंग है हम क्या करते हैं जब भी
क्या करते हैं अपना ब्राउजर ओपन करते हैं
ब्राउजर में कोई भी एप्लीकेशन ओपन करते
हैं या हम आउटलुक ओपन करते हैं या
हम कोई भी जीमेल ओपन करते हैं कोई भी
एप्लीकेशन ओपन करते हैं तो हम क्या करते
हैं डायरेक्टली किसके साथ इंटरेक्ट करते
हैं एप्लीकेशन लेयर के साथ इंटरेक्ट करते
हैं और जो आपकी एप्लीकेशन लेयर है क्योंकि
अगर वोह आपकी नेटवर्क बेस्ड एप्लीकेशन है
तो नेटवर्क से कम्युनिकेशन करने के लिए
कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है
तो उनके बीच में क्या होती है जो नेटवर्क
सर्विसेस प्रोवाइड करने के के लिए आपकी जो
एप्लीकेशन है इंटरफेस का काम करती है तो
इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर प्रोवाइड नेटवर्क
सर्विसेस डायरेक्टली टू द एप्लीकेशन एंड
फैसिलिटेटिंग वेरियस नेटवर्क बेस्ड फंक्शन
लाइक वेब ब्राउजिंग फाइल ट्रांसफर ईमेल
कम्युनिकेशन एंड मोर जब भी आप क्या करते
हैं जो आपका जो एंड यूजर एप्लीकेशन है और
जो नेटवर्क है इनके बीच में जो इंटरफेस का
काम करती है वो एप्लीकेशन लेयर करती है जो
भी नेटवर्क सर्विसेस प्रोवाइड करने का काम
करती है वो भी क्या करती है आपकी
एप्लीकेशन लेयर ही करती है एप्लीकेशन ही
लेयर ही उसके लिए रिस्पांसिबल
है दिस ले इ द क्लोजेस्ट टू द एंड यूजर
एंड रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
इंश्योरिटी करेक्टली बिटवीन एप्लीकेशन
रनिंग ऑन डिफरेंट सिस्टम ओके एंड इट
इनेबल्स सॉफ्टवेयर ऑन वन मशीन टू
कम्युनिकेट विद द सॉफ्टवेयर ऑन अनदर मशीन
वाया द नेटवर्क ओके यह भी इंश्योर करती है
कि जो एक सॉफ्टवेयर है एक मशीन के ऊपर और
जो दूसरा सॉफ्टवेयर है दूसरी मशीन के ऊपर
वो अच्छे तरीके से कम्युनिकेट कर पाए
नेटवर्क के थ्रू क्योंकि उसके अकॉर्डिंग
ही ये प्रोटोकॉल्स आपको प्रोवाइड करती है
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल्स
ओ नाउ अब बात करते हैं कि एप्लीकेशन लेयर
की फंक्शनल क्या है जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर है
उसकी फंक्शनल क्या-क्या है उसके बारे में
बात करते हैं
तो सबसे पहले है नेटवर्क सर्विसेस फॉर
एप्लीकेशन जो एप्लीकेशन है उनके लिए
नेटवर्क सर्विस प्रोवाइड करने का काम करती
है ओके तो मे भी मुझे इसको एक्सप्लेन करने
की जरूरत नहीं है तो इसको आप खुद से भी
पढ़ सकते हो कि मैं मैक्सिमम ट्राई करूंगा
कि जिस ट जिस पॉइंट को मुझे एक्सप्लेन
करने की रिक्वायरमेंट उसको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा और जिसको एक्सप्लेन करने की
रिक्वायरमेंट है उसको आप नोट्स के थ्रू
पढ़ सकते हो सेकंड पॉइंट क्या है
एप्लीकेशन स्पेसिफिक डाटा कम्युनिकेशन ओके
कि दिस लेयर इशो दैट डेटा इज प्रॉपर्ली
कम्युनिकेटेड बिटवीन एप्लीकेशंस इट पैकेज
द डाटा फॉर ट्रांसमिशन एंड इंश्योर दैट
करेक्ट प्रोटोकॉल्स आर यूज्ड फॉर
स्पेसिफिक एप्लीकेशन फॉर एग्जांपल व्हेन ए
यूजर रिक्वेस्ट ए वेब पेज द एप्लीकेशन
लेयर इन द वेब ब्राउजर यूज द एटीटीपी या
एटीटीपी एस टू इनिशिएटिव टू द सर्वर मतलब
क्या है कि एप्लीकेशन को कम्युनिकेशन करने
के लिए कि उसके अकॉर्डिंग जो स्पेसिफिक
प्रोटोकॉल्स वैलिड प्रोटोकॉल्स है जो जिस
प्रोटोकॉल की उसको रिक्वायरमेंट है उसको
प्रोवाइड करती है यह एप्लीकेशन लेयर
नेक्स्ट एंड यूजर इंटरफेस द एप्लीकेशन
लेयर प्रोवाइड्स एन इंटरफेस थ्रो विच एंड
यूजर इंटरेक्ट विद नेटवर्क एप्लीकेशंस वही
चीज है इट डायरेक्टली कम्युनिकेट विद
सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन टू मेक नेटवर्क
सर्विसेस एक्सेसिबल टू द यूजर बेसिकली अभी
मैंने बताया था कि जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर है
वो एंड यूजर के जो अ एंड यूजर आपका जो
एप्लीकेशन लेयर से ही क्या करता है
इंटरेक्ट करता है और यह आपके एप्लीकेशंस
को सर्विस नेटवर्क सर्विस प्रोवाइड करती
है जो भी नेटवर्क एप्लीकेशन होती है
नेक्स्ट डटा रिप्रेजेंटेशन एप्लीकेशन लेयर
आल्सो डिफाइन हाउ डाटा शुड बी
रिप्रेजेंटेड इंश्योर दैट इट इज इन ए
फॉर्मेट दैट कैन बी अंडरस्टूड बाय द
रेसिपिटिन ओके ओके फॉर एग्जांपल इफ यू आर
सेंडिंग एन ईमेल द एसएमटीपी प्रोटोकॉल इन
द एप्लीकेशन लेयर फॉर्मेट द डाटा फॉर
एग्जांपल ईमेल टेक्स्ट या अटैचमेंट इन ए
वे दैट कैन बी इंटरप्रिटेड बाय द
रिसिपिएंट ईमेल एप्लीकेशन ओके आप क्या
करते हो कोई भी डाटा है उसको क्या करते हो
फॉर एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया वेब ब्राउजर
ओपन किया वेब ब्राउजर में आपने
एप्लीकेशन लेयर उसके अकॉर्डिंग जो
प्रोटोकॉल यूज होगा जैसे एसएमटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल है उसको यूज करेगी उस डाटा को
क्या करेगी नेक्स्ट लेयर के पास फॉरवर्ड
कर देगी नाउ रिसोर्स शेयरिंग का में अगर
हमें रिसोर्सेस शेयर करने हैं फॉर एपल
जैसे कि एफटीपी के थ्रू तब भी आपकी
एप्लीकेशन लेयर ही के थ्रू आप क्या करते
हो इंटरेक्ट करते हो नाउ दिस इज द फंक्शन
ऑफ द एप्लीकेशन लेयर नाउ दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ
प्रोटोकॉल्स दैट आर यूज्ड ऑन द एप्लीकेशन
लेयर एचटीटीपी एटीपीएस एफटीपी एसएफटीपी
एसएमटीपी आई मैप पॉप 3 डीएनएस डीएसीपी
एसएनएमपी टेलनेट एडेप
आरडीपी सिंपल ऑब्जेक्ट एक्सेस प्रोटोकॉल
एक्सटेंसिबल मैसेजिंग एंड प्रेजेंस
प्रोटोकॉल नेटवर्क फाइल सिस्टम कॉमन
इंटरनेट फाइल सिस्टम एम क्यूटी सिप
एफटीपीएस बीजीपी एम एपीआई मतलब बहुत सारे
प्रोटोकॉल्स का नाम आपने सुना भी नहीं
होगा जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर पे काम करते हैं
तो मे बी एवरीवन क्लियर व्हाट इज द
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज ऑफ एप्लीकेशन
लेयर ओके
अनिमी मैं आपको बताता हूं क्या नाम है बलो
ओसाई मॉडल नहीं पढ़ाया गया हो आपको बट
आपको एक चीज बताई होगी टीसीपी यूडीपी आपने
सीखा होगा ओके तो टीसीपी यूडीपी के बेस पर
आपने टूल यूज किए होंगे एन मैप टूल यूज हो
आई एम शर कि हर किसी ने एन मैप टूल यूज
किया होगा जब आप एन मैप टूल यूज करते हो
तो आपको पता है कि वह कैसे काम करता
है पता है किसी को एन मैप टूल्स की
डिटेल्स वर्किंग क्या
है टीसीपी यूडीपी आप पढ़ लेते हो एडीटीपी
आप पढ़ लेते हो बट वह काम कैसे करते हैं
आपका पूरा नेटवर्क ही कैसे काम करता है डू
यू नो जब आपको यही नहीं हो नेटवर्क कैसे
काम करता है मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ना पहले
आपका आपका एक बहुत बड़ा सिलेबस उसको मैं
नरो डाउन करता करता करता करता साइबर फील्ड
में लेकर जाऊंगा आपको एजेक्ट पता चल जाए
कि जिस चीज पर मैं काम कर रहा अभी जिस चीज
पर अटैक कर रहा हूं जिस चीज इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग कर रहा हूं वह किसका पार्ट है मैं
रिलेट कर रहा हूं
आपको चलो अभी हम बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर प्र
लेयर लेयर सिक्स ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल एंड इज
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर ट्रांसलेशन इंक्रिप्शन
एंड कंप्रेशन ऑफ डाटा बिटवीन द एप्लीकेशन
लेयर एंड द लोअर लेयर ओके जो प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर है उसका क्या काम है आपके डाटा का
इंक्रिप्शन करना डिक्रिप्शन करना या उस
डाटा को ट्रांसलेट करना इट इंश्योर दैट द
डाटा सेंट बाय द एप्लीकेशन लेयर इज इन
रीडेबल फॉर्मेट फॉर द रिसीविंग एप्लीकेशन
एंड ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर द नेटवर्क द
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर एक्ट एज ए ट्रांसलेटर
एंड प्रिपेयर द डाटा फॉर द एप्लीकेशन लेयर
एंड इंश्योर इट इज प्रेजेंटेड इन एन
अंडरस्टैंडेबल फॉर्म फॉर बोथ एंड्स ऑफ ए
कम्युनिकेशन सेशन जब आपकी एप्लीकेशन लेयर
क्या करती है डाटा को सेंड करती है
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर के पास भेजती है तो
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर क्या करता है उस डाटा को
ऐसे फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करता है
जो एक स्टैंडर्ड फॉर्मेट है मतलब हर एक
डिवाइस प उसको ट्रांसमिट किया जा सकता है
हर एक डिवाइस उसको समझता है हो सकता है कि
आपकी एप्लीकेशन उस डाटा को किस फॉर्म में
समझती है बट इंटरनेट जो आपका स्टैंडर्ड
फॉर्मेट है उसी को समझेगा तो उस स्टैंडर्ड
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करने का काम भी क्या है
प्रेजेंटेशन लेर दूसरा
अगर सिक्योर डाटा है तो उसको इनक्रिप्ट और
डिक्रिप्ट करने का भी काम किसका है बिफोर
ट्रांसमिशन इनक्रिप्ट करने का काम और यूजर
के पास जो रिसीवर है उसको रिप्रेजेंट करने
से पहले उसको डिक्रिप्ट करने का काम भी
क्या है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का ही है ओके
दोनों ही केस में चाहे वो रिसीवर साइड हो
चाहे वो सेंडर साइड
हो नाउ अभी फंक्शन ऑफ द प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर डाटा ट्रांसलेशन मैंने आपको बता दिया
आप इसको डिटेल में पढ़ लेना मैं आपको भेज
दूंगा कि वन डाटा इ सेंड फ्रॉम एन
एप्लीकेशन इट कुड बी इन वेरियस फॉर्मेट सच
अ टेक्स्ट इमेज वीडियो द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज फॉर्मेटेड प्रॉपर्ली
सो दैट इट कैन बी इंटरप्रिटेड बाय द
रिसीविंग
एप्लीकेशन फॉर एग्जांपल इट कैन कन्वर्ट
डाटा फ्रॉम वन कैरेक्टर इनकोडिंग आस्का टू
अनदर कैरेक्टर इनकोडिंग यूकोड ओके नाउ
दूसरी फंक्शन टी क्या है डाटा कंप्रेशन यह
क्या होता है द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर ऑफ
कंप्रेसेस डाटा टू रिड्यूस द
अमाउंट ऑफ डाटा ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर द नेटवर्क
इंप्रूविंग ट्रांसमिशन एफिशिएंसी एंड
स्पीड क्या होता है कि कई बार जो आपकी
एप्लीकेशन लेयर है बहुत लार्ज अमाउंट में
डाटा को ट्रांसफर करती है बहुत बड़े साइज
में तो उसको क्या करते है आपकी प्रेजेंट
ले उस डाटा को कंप्रेस भी करती है कंप्रेस
करके उस डाटा को ट्रांसमिट करने का काम
करती है ताकि जो नेटवर्क एफिशिएंसी है वो
स्पीड बनी रहे ठीक है और जो उसकी बैंड वेज
ू है वो भी बनी रहे ऐसा नहीं कि वो पूरा
डाटा एज इट इज भेज दिया और नेटवर्क स्टक
हो गया उस परे ट्रैफिक ही लग गया ऐसा कुछ
ऐसा नहीं होना
चाहिए नाउ थर्ड पॉइंट है डाटा इंक्रिप्शन
एंड डिक्रिप्शन डिक्रिप्शन ओके ये आपको
बता चुका हूं नाउ सिंटेक्स एंड सेंटिक्स
का मतलब क्या होता है द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
इंश्योर दैट द सिंटेक्स जो स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ
डाटा एंड सेंटिक्स जो मीनिंग ऑफ द डाटा आर
करेक्ट एंड कंसिस्टेंट बिटवीन द टू
कम्युनिकेटिंग सिस्टम मतलब जिस स्ट्रक्चर
में डाटा को भेजा गया है और जो डाटा का
मतलब है व उसी फॉर्म में रहे उसके साथ
क्या करें उसके साथ छेड़छाड़ ना हो
कम्युनिकेशन सिस्टम के बीच में तो उसकी
इंटीग्रिटी मेंटेन करने का काम भी क्या
करता है मतलब प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पे ही होता
है इफ वन सिस्टम यूज अ पर्टिकुलर कैरेक्टर
इनकोडिंग एंड द अदर सिस्टम यूज इज अ
डिफरेंट वन द द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
ट्रांसलेट दिस इनटू ए कॉमन फॉर्मेट सो दैट
डाटा इज करेक्टली इंटरप्रिटेड ओके एक कॉमन
फॉर्मेट में चेंज कर देगा सॉफ्टवेयर कुछ
भी समझता हो लेकिन जब उसको इंटरनेट प
डिलीवर किया जाएगा उसको एक कॉमन फॉर्मेट
में डिलीवर किया जाएगा डाटा फॉर्मेटिंग द
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज
प्रॉपर्ली फॉर्मेटेड फॉर द एप्लीकेशन ऑन द
रिसीविंग एंड ओके उसको सही तरीके से
फॉर्मेट किया गया है फॉर एग्जांपल
कन्वर्टिंग डाटा फ्रॉम एक्सएमएल फॉर्मेट
टू जेसन एंड जेसन टू एक्सएमएल डिपेंडिंग
ऑन द नीड्स ऑफ द सॉफ्टवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर के
नीड्स पे डिपेंड करता है दिस इज द वर्क ऑफ
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर नाउ प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पर
कौन-कौन से प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज किए जाते हैं
एसएसएल टी एलएस सबने सुना होगा जेपीजी
जेएफ एमपीजी स्काई
यूकोड बहुत सारे प्रोटोकॉल आपने सुने भी
नहीं होंगे एक्स 400 एमआई एमई आरडीपी
एसएनएमपी पीजीपी वीएनसी टीएफटीपी एंड एक्स
500 दीज आर दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल
दैट आर यूज्ड ऑन द प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
एवरीवन गट क्लियर अबाउट द प्रेजेंटेशन
लेयर बेसिकली डाटा रिप्रेजेंटेशन का काम
क्या है प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का काम है
एप्लीकेशन का काम क्या है इंटरेक्शन
नेटवर्क सर्विसेस को प्रोवाइड करना एंड
यूजर एप्लीकेशन को
नॉट
क्लियर तो बताइए
[संगीत]
कि प्लीज एक्सप्लेन अगेन
ओके तो बेसिकली मैं आपको बताता हूं जब भी
आपने एप्लीकेशन को ओपन किया फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं अभी बात
करूं यह रही यह रहा फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी
क्या करता हूं यह एप्लीकेशन रन की मैंने
यहां पर मैंने ओपन किया
डेनिक्स ट एंटर जैसे मैंने इस एप्लीकेशन
में क्लिक किया देखिए तो इसमें क्या किया
अब fix.com क्या है एक होस्टिंग सर्वर
मतलब एक डोमेन है ठीक है डोमेन है अभी
जैसे मैंने यहां पर क्लिक किया यूआरएल के
अंदर तो यहां पर इंटरेक्ट मैं किसके साथ
कर रहा हूं ब्राउजर के थ्रू कर रहा हूं
ब्राउजर एक एप्लीकेशन ही है ठीक है लेकिन
एप्लीकेशन लेयर पर क्या क्या काम हो रहा
है कि इसके अकॉर्डिंग कौन सी ये एसटीटी प
सर्विस ले रहा है तो इसको सर्विस प्रोवाइड
कौन कर रहा है एप्लीकेशन लेयर ओके देन
मेरे स्क्रीन पे क्या डाटा शो हो रहा है
इंग्लिश में अकॉर्डिंग टू दिस वेबसाइट यह
डाटा इंग्लिश में शो हो रहा है बट अगर मैं
देखिए मुझे मिल के आ रहा है डाटा अगर
देखोगे तो इसको अगर मैं इसको देखूंगा तो
व्यू मोर टूल
एंड डेवलपर टूल दीज आर द डाटा देखिए इस
फॉर्म में डाटा आपका आ रहा है देखिए यह
क्या है एचटीएमएल है सीएसएस है
जावास्क्रिप्ट है लेकिन इस फॉर्म में डाटा
आया
लेकिन जब ये ट्रांसमिशन किया जाएगा हो
सकता है कि कोई डिवाइस इसको भी स्पोर्ट
नहीं कर रहा हो इसको भी वो नहीं कर रहा हो
तो इसका भी एक कॉमन फॉर्मेट भेजा जाएगा तो
समझ पा रहे हो कि डेटा रिप्रेजेंटेशन
किसका काम है अभी एचटीटीपीएस यूज हो रहा
है मतलब एचएसएल टीएल एस मतलब क्या
इंक्रिप्शन डिक्रिप्शन हो रहा है तो वो
किसका काम है आपके प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का
काम है तो बेसिकली इतना ही बताया मैंने
आपको
क
ओके नाउ नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं सेशन लेयर
जो आपका लेयर नंबर फाइव सेशन लेयर लेयर
फाइव ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल इ रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
स्टेबलिंग
मैनेजिंग एंड टर्मिनेटिंग कम्युनिकेशन
सेशन बिटवीन टू सिस्टम और
एप्लीकेशंस बेसिकली क्या है कि आपके सेशन
को मैनेज करने के लिए उसको सही तरीके से
टर्मिनेट करने के लिए और उसको एस्टेब्लिश
करने के काम आता आपका सेशन लेयर जब भी आप
क्या करते हो एग्जांपल अगर आपके पास
एसबीआई बैंकिंग एसबीआई का नेट बैंकिंग आप
यूज करते तो कभी भी देखना जब आप नेट
बैंकिंग यूज करते हो और कुछ टाइम के लिए
उसके क्लिक भी नहीं करते अनअटेंडेड छोड़
देते हो उसका क्या करते हो सेशन ऑटोमेटिक
टाइम आउट हो जाता है मतलब क्या है उस सेशन
को मैनेज करने का काम किसका है सेशन लेयर
ए सेशन लेयर इज एसेंशियली ए डायलॉग और ए
कनेक्शन बिटवीन टू एंड पॉइंट फॉर द पर्पस
ऑफ कम्युनिकेशन द सेशन लेयर इंश्योर दैट
दज डायलॉग्स आर प्रॉपर्ली मेंटेन
सिंक्रोनाइज एंड ऑर्गेनाइज ये दोनों सेशन
को सही तरह से मेंटेन किया जाए
सिंक्रोनाइज किया जाए और सही तरीके से
ऑर्गेनाइज किया जाए सेशन लेयर इज लोकेटेड
बिटवीन द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर च इज द लेयर
नंबर फोर एंड प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर लेयर नंबर
सिक्स इन दोनों के बीच में क्या है
लोकेटेड है नाउ अभी बात करते हैं फंक्शनल
ऑफ द सेशन लेयर सबसे पहली क्या है सेशन
एस्टेब्लिशमेंट मेंटेनेंस एंड टर्मिनेशन
ओके इस सेशन को एस्टेब्लिश करना मेंटेन
करना और टर्मिनेट करना खास करके ड्यूरिंग
कब वन जब टू कंप्यूटर्स आर कम्युनिकेटिंग
वाया ए प्रोटोकॉल लाइक एचटीटीपी एफटीपी द
सेशन लेयर एस्टेब्लिश द कनेक्शन एंड मैनेज
द सेशन फॉर द एंटायस फर कभी आपने देखा कि
जब डाटा ट्रांसफर कर रहे हो या जब भी आप
कोई वेबसाइट सर्व कर रहे हो या वेबसाइट पर
काम कर रहे होते हो या नेट बैंकिंग आप यूज
कर रहे हो तो कभी भी ऐसे हो कि सडन सेशन
आउट हो गया हो नहीं होता क्योंकि जब आप
उसको यूज करो तो उस सेशन को मेंटेन करने
का काम सेफ तरीके से वो सेशन लेयर का काम
है ठीक है पूरी तर जब आप उस सेशन को
अनअटेंडेड छोड़ देते हो जब आप उस सेशन को
यूज नहीं कर रहे उस एप्लीकेशन को यूज नहीं
कर रहे होते तब वह सेशन क्या है अच्छे
तरीके से क्या है टर्मिनेट भी सेशन लेयर
के द्वारा ही किया जाता है ओके नाउ अभी
बात करते हैं सेकंड डायलॉग कंट्रोल का
मतलब क्या है द सेशन लेयर कंट्रोल द फ्लो
ऑफ डाटा बिटवीन एप्लीकेशंस इट इंश्योर ट
डेटा इज ट्रांसमिटेड इन ए वे दैट बोथ
डिवाइसेज कैन अंडरस्टैंड एंड इट मैनेस हाउ
डाटा इज सेंट बैक एंड फोर्थ वेदर ए फुल
डुप्लेक्स और हाफ डुप्लेक्स वे बेसिकली
डायलॉग कंटर मतलब क्या है कि अब ये भी
डिसाइड यही करती है कि कि मोड ऑफ
कम्युनिकेशन क्या है वन वे है या टू वे है
कि हाफ डुप्लेक्स या फुल डुप्लेक्स है ये
भी सेशन लेयर पे डिसाइड होता है अगर हाफ
डुप्लेक्स का मतलब क्या होता है कि ओनली
एक टाइम में एक ही डिवाइस क्या कर पाएगा
कम्युनिकेट कर पाएगा फुल डुप्लेक्स का
मतलब क्या है कि सेंडर भी अपना डाटा भेज
पा रहा है और रिसीवर भी अपना डाटा भेज पा
रहा है लेकिन दोनों अगर एक साथ भी डाटा
सेंड कर देते हैं फिर भी आपको क्या है आगे
पीछे ही वह डाटा मिलता है क्यों इस तरीके
को इस तरीके का सेशन मेंटेन करता है आपका
सेशन लेयर फॉर एग्जांपल इन ए वीडियो कॉल द
सेशन लेयर मैनेस हाउ द वीडियो एंड ऑडियो
डाटा आर एक्सचेंज बिटवीन डिवा बोथ
डायरेक्शन यू नो वेरी वेल कि वीडियो कॉल
एक गुड एग्जांपल है आपका सेशन लेयर का
फोर्थ थर्ड पॉइंट है सिंक्रोनाइजेशन द
सेशन लेयर इ रिस्पांसिबल फॉर एडिंग
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन पॉइंट इन द डेटा स्ट्रीम
टू इंश्योर डटा इंटीग्रिटी ड्यूरिंग
ट्रांसमिशन अभी सिंक्रोनाइजेशन पॉइंट डेटा
स्ट्रीम के अंदर कुछ चेक पॉइंट्स ऐड करने
का काम भी किसका है सेशन लेयर काम इट
इंश्योर दैट लार्ज अमाउंट ऑफ डटा कैन बी
ब्रोकन इनटू स्मॉलर सेगमेंट एंड डाटा कैन
बी रिअसेंबल्ड करेक्टली एट द रिसीविंग एंड
चेक पॉइंट का मतलब क्या होता है द सेशन
लेयर कैन इंसर्ट चेक पॉइंट एट स्पेसिफिक
पॉइंट्स ड्यूरिंग द कम्युनिकेशन इफ
कनेक्शन इज लॉस्ट या इंटरप्टेड इट कैन
रिज्यूम फ्रॉम द लास्ट चेक पॉइंट इंस्टेड
ऑफ स्टार्टिंग ओवर कहने का मतलब क्या है
कि सेशन लेयर क्या करती है कि डेटा
स्ट्रिम के अंदर चेक पॉइंट ऐड कर देती है
ताकि
अगर बिग अमाउंट में डाटा है तो उसको क्या
किया जाता है सेगमेंट में छोटे छोटे
टुकड़ों में क्या कर सकते हैं हम भेजते
हैं तो उस टाइम पे क्या है कि जिस तरीके
से डाटा भेजा गया उस तरीके से उसको
रिअसेंबल किया जाएगा दूसरा क्या है अगर
किसी भी कान से डाटा लॉस हो गया इंटरप्ट
हो गया सेशन ठीक है डाटा मतलब सेशन आपका
इंटरप्ट हो गया तो उस टाइम में क्या है
डाटा लॉस ना हो तब भी वो चेक पॉइंट उसके
अंदर डेटा स्ट्रीम के अंदर रहता है कि
उससे रहेगा कि लास्ट टाइम इस चेक पॉइंट प
जाकर आप डाटा इंटरप्ट हुआ था ताकि आपका
सेशन दोबारा से रीस्टार्ट ना करना पड़े कई
बार क्या होता है की बफरिंग हो जाती है कई
बार आपने देखा होगा कि
youtube2 इंश्योर दैट इफ दी कनेक्शन फेल्स
द फाइल कैन बी रिज्यूम्ड फ्रॉम वे इट इज
लेफ्ट ऑफ रदर देन रीस्टार्टिंग द एंटायस
फर ओके अभी बात करते हैं एक और सेशन ओके
नेक्स्ट फंक्शन टीज की क्या है सॉरी सेशन
रिकवरी इफ ए कम्युनिकेशन सेशन इज
इंटरप्टेड ड्यू टू नेटवर्क इशू दि सेशन
लेयर कैन हेल्प टू रिकवर द सेशन यह मैं
आपको बताया अभी एग्जांपल के थ्रू सेशन
डायलॉग मैनेजमेंट का काम भी किसका है सेशन
लेयर का दिस सेशन लेयर मैनेज हाउ द
कम्युनिकेशन सेशन आर स्ट्रक्चर्ड दिस मींस
इट एस्टेब्लिश एंड मैनेज द रूल्स फॉर डाटा
एक्सचेंज मतलब कौन इस सेशन पे डाटा सेंड
कर सकता है कौन इस सेशन पे डाटा सेंड नहीं
कर सकता कौन इस सेशन को जवाइन कर सकता है
कौन जॉइन नहीं कर सकता बेसिकली हाफ
डुप्लेक्स यूज़ होगा या फुल डुप्लेक्स
यूज़ होगा ड्यूरिंग कम्युनिकेशन यह सारी
चीज़ें भी सेशन लेयर पे ही डिसाइड की जाती
है दीज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ़ प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज्ड
ऑन द सेशन लेयर नेट बायोस आरपीसी
एसएमबी पॉइंट टू पॉइंट टनलिंग प्रोटोकॉल्स
एसक्यूएल जज आर लॉट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल ट आर यूज
ऑन द सेशन लेयर बहुत सार प्रोटोकॉल है जो
आपने सुने भी नहीं होंगे अगर आप लोगों को
हर एक प्रोटोकॉल के बारे में जानना है तो
गल कीजिए हर एक प्रोटोकॉल को हम डिटेल में
कवर नहीं कर सकते हां जिन प्रोटोकॉल की
रिक्वायरमेंट है ड्यूरिंग
अपने ट्रेनिंग उन प्रोटोकॉल्स को हम फिर
भी समझेंगे और उस परे हंट भी करेंगे
बेसिकली हम उस परे ट्राई भी
करेंगे नोट्स ऑन प्रायोरिटी मैं आपको
दूंगा
अपलोड तो यहां तक क्लियर है सेशन लेयर
तक ओके नेक्स्ट बात करते हम ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर की अब ये ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर क्या होती
है देखिए द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर लेयर फोर ऑफ
द ओआई मॉडल इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
इंश्योरिटी डाटा को ट्रांसपोर्टेशन मतलब
कि ट्रांसपोर्टेशन बो समझते हो ना कि अगर
मुझे कोई भी डिलीवरी करनी है फॉर एंप
कूरियर का एग्जांपल ले ले आप कोई भी
पार्सल करना लेटर या कुछ भी तो कुछ कंपनी
होती है जो ट्रांसपोर्टेशन का काम करती है
तो वही काम य करती है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सीधा एग्जांपल है इट एब्लिश मेंटेन
टर्मिनेट कनेक्शन कंट्रोल द फ्लो ऑफ डाटा
एंड हैंडल एरर डिटेक्शन एंड करेक्शन दोनों
सारी चीजें क्या करती है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
ही हैंडल करती है
ओके डोंट वरी आई विल
एक्सप्लेन द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सर्व एस द
इंटरमीडियरी बिटवीन द सेशन लेयर एंड
नेटवर्क लेयर अभी बात करते हैं फंक्शनल ऑफ
द ट्रांसफर लेयर अगर अभी आपको कुछ चीजें
कंफ्यूज कर रही हैं तो वेट फॉर द एंड आई
विल क्लियर एवरीथिंग बट सेशन छोड़ के मत
जाना सबसे पहला एंड टू एंड कम्युनिकेशन
सबसे मेन रोल है आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का
एंड टू एंड कम्युनिकेशन मेंटेन करके रखना
द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर प्रोवाइड्स एंड टू एंड
कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन डिवाइसेज अक्रॉस
डिफरेंट नेटवर्क्स इट इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज
डिलीवर्ड रिलायबली इन ऑर्डर एंड विदाउट
डुप्लीकेशन और लॉस ओके इवन इफ द अंडरलाइन
नेटवर्क लेयर कैन नॉट गारंटी इट ओके
बेसिकली क्या है कि एप्लीकेशन लेयर तो जो
सेशन लेयर तो मेक श्योर कर रही थी लेकिन
काम करने का काम क्या है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
पे भी होता है ये काम ठीक है और डाटा एरर
डिटेक्शन करना डाटा डुप्लीकेशन से बचाना
लॉस होने से बचाना उसको रिलायबली
ट्रांसपोर्ट करना इस इसका क्या है
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का काम है
दे सम टर्म्स चच विल यू कंफ्यूज बट इन द
कंप्लीशन ऑफ ऑल सेवन लेवस मैं आपको एक
सिनेरियो बेस पर समझाऊ तब आपके सारे डाउट
क्लियर हो जाएंगे इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
सेगमेंट डाटा फ्रॉम अप्पर लेयर इनटू
स्मॉलर पीस फॉर ट्रांसमिशन एंड
रिअसेंबलिंग इट एट द डेस्टिनेशन ओके जो
डाटा आपका एप्लीकेशन लेयर से आपका
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर से या सेशन लेयर से आ
रहा है बेसिकली क्या है किस आहा डटा की
फॉर्म में ही आ रहा है ठीक है तो उस डाटा
को सेगमेंट किया जाता है आपके ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर पर छोटे-छोटे
पीस में उसको डिवाइड किया जाता है चंक्स
में डिवाइड किया जाता है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
पर सेगमेंटेशन एंड
रिअसेंबली कहां पर होती है ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर के ऊपर तो यू विल आप इसको क्या कर
सकते हो खुद से पढ़ सकते हो सेल्फ
एक्सप्लेनेटरी है फ्लो कंट्रोल फ्लो
कंट्रोल इज इंप्लीमेंटेड टू इंश्योर दैट
दिस सेंडर डज नॉट ओवर विलम द रिसीवर विद
टू मच डाटा टू क्विकली मतलब द ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर रेगुलेट द रेट एट व्हिच डाटा इज सेंट
बाय द सेंडर बेस्ड ऑन द रिसीवर एबिलिटी टू
प्रोसेस एंड स्टोर द इनकमिंग डाटा हो सकता
है कि सेंडर के पास जो डेटा की बैंड विड्थ
हो ज्यादा हो रिसीवर के पास डाटा की बैंड
विड्थ कम हो तो उसके अकॉर्डिंग डाटा का
फ्लो कंट्रोल क्या ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के
द्वारा ही किया जाता है कि ठीक है सेंडर
के पास डाटा बैंड विड थी ज्यादा थी उसने
सार डाटा एक साथ में ट्रांसफर कर दिया
अपने नेटवर्क से निकाल दिया लेकिन भैया एक
रिसीवर की एबिलिटी होगी उसका नेटवर्क
कमजोर होगा या उसकी एक लिमिटेशंस होगी कि
वो डाटा को इतने डाटा को एक साथ नहीं ले
सकता तो क्या करेगा वो पीसीज में लेगा
ंक्स में लेगा ठीक है या बिल्कुल आराम
आराम से मतलब थोड़ा-थोड़ा डाटा लेगा तो वो
उसका फ्लो कंट्रोल करने का काम भी किसका
है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का एरर डिटेक्शन एंड
करेक्शन के लिए भी रिस्पांसिबल क्या है
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर डिटेक्टिंग एंड करेक्टिंग
एरर्स दैट में अकर ड्यूरिंग
ट्रांसमिशन इट इंशोर डाटा इंटीग्रिटी बाय
चेकिंग फॉर एरर्स इन द ट्रांसमिटेड
सेगमेंट अब सेगमेंट्स क्या करते हैं कि
अभी वह क्या है छोटे-छोटे चंक्स ऑफ डाटा
है कि उनको क्या करता है जब सेंड करने के
बाद क्या है कि जिस चंक्स ऑफ डेटा जितने
भी चस ऑफ डेटा सेंड किया जिस वे में सेंड
किया गया उसी वे में उनको क्या किया जाता
है रिअसेंबल किया जाता है आपके रिसीविंग
साइड में ओके अगर देखो एरर डिटेक्शन किसी
भी कारण से हो सकता है मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल
जो एरर है किसी भी कारण से क्रिएट हो सकती
है नेटवर्क के कारण किसी भी तो उसको
डिटेक्ट करने का काम भी क्या है
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर को डिटेक्ट करके उसके
बाद लगता है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर को कि नहीं
डाटा को री ट्रांसफर्ट करना चाहिए तो उसको
रिट्रांसमिट करती है
नाउ रिलायबल डाटा डिलीवरी ओबवियसली
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिशमेंट मेंटेनेंस एंड
टर्मिनेशन यह भी एंड इसी पर किया जाता है
एंड मल्टीप्लेक्सिंग भी फंक्शनल है किसकी
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर की द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
अलाउ मल्टीपल एप्लीकेशन टू शेयर द सेम
नेटवर्क कनेक्शन अभी यह चीज ध्यान से
समझना कि जो ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पर आप क्या
कर सकते बहुत जितने भी एप्लीकेशंस है क्या
करती है सेम नेटवर्क कनेक्शन पर क्या कर
सकती है डाटा सेंड कर सकती है दे लॉट ऑफ
एप्लीकेशन बट क्या करते हैं वे यज पोर्ट
नंबर टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन और प्रोसेस द डाटा शुड बी
सेंड टू ऑन द डेस्टिनेशन डिवाइड डिवाइस
ओके अभी ठीक है सारी की सारी
एप्लीकेशन सेम नेटवर्क में डाटा ट्रांसफर
करती है लेकिन किस एप्लीकेशन का डाटा किस
एप्लीकेशन पर जाना चाहिए वो भी ट्रांस
ट्रांसफर ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पे किया जाता
डिसाइड किया जाता है वाया पोर्ट नंबर
क्योंकि ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पे पोर्ट असाइन
किया जाता है ठीक है नाउ उसके बाद दीज आर
द लिस्ट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज्ड बाय द
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर टीसीपी यूडीपी एससीटीपी
डीसीसीपी आरटीपी आरसीपी दीज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ
प्रोटोकॉल यूज न ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर हमारे
लिए टीसीपी और यूडीपी है और सारा
ट्रांसपोर्टेशन का काम इंटरनेट पे
मैक्सिमम क्या टीसीपी यूडीपी ही करते हैं
रिलायबिलिटी की गारंटी देता है आपका
टीसीपी और और डाटा को सही ढंग से ना
पहुंचाने की नोट रिलेबल की गारंटी देता है
यूडीपी अब टीसीपी पोर्ट कैसे काम करता है
यूडीपी पोर्ट कैसे काम करता है आई विल
एक्सप्लेन फर्द अपकमिंग क्लासेस ओके नाउ
आपको ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर समझ में आ
गई आप सबको ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर समझ में आ गई
दे ओनली 45 स्टूडेंट्स ओके नो ड नो वरी
अगर आपको छोड़ के जाना है क्लास छोड़ सकते
हो नो
इशू नाउ अभी बात करते हैं नेटवर्क लेयर की
नेटवर्क लेयर इज द थर्ड लेयर ऑफ द ओएआई
मॉडल ओके एंड इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
फैसिलिटेटिंग द ट्रांसफर ऑफ डाटा बिटवीन
डिवाइसेज ऑन ए डिफरेंट नेटवर्क्स ओके ठीक
है इट इंश्योर ट डाटा पैकेट्स आर
प्रॉपर्ली राउड फ्रॉम द सोर्स डिवाइस टू द
डेस्टिनेशन डिवाइस अक्रॉस डावर्स एंड
पोटेंशियली
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पे था वह
सेगमेंट की फॉर्म में था उसको पैकेट की
फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करती है आपकी नेटवर्क
लेयर उसके बाद नेटवर्क लेयर उसके अंदर
लॉजिकल एड्रेस ऐड करती है क्या करती है
लॉजिकल एड्रेस ऐड करती है लॉजिकल एड्रेस
क्या होता है आपका आईपी एड्रेस होता है एक
यूनिक आइडेंटिटी होती है आपके किसकी
डिवाइस की सो दैट की उसी के पास वो डाटा
जाए और ये क्या है सोर्स और डेस्टिनेशन
मतलब जहां से जा रहा हो जिसके पास जाना वो
दोनों की दोनों चीजें क्या करता है
नेटवर्क लेयर अपने पैकेट के अंदर
इंप्लीमेंट करती है ऐड करती है ओके और
उसके बाद राउटिंग
नाउ फंक्शन ऑफ द नेटवर्क लेयर अभी जो
फंक्शन है वह नेटवर्क लेयर की उसके बारे
में बात करते हैं राउटिंग सबसे पहले द
नेटवर्क लेयर इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
डिटरमाइंस पाथ फॉर डेटा टू ट्रेवल आईपी
एड्रेस प्लस में बेस्ट पाथ डेटा ट्रेवल
करने के लिए फ्रॉम द सोर्स टू द
डेस्टिनेशन अक्रॉस इंटरमीडिएट नेटवर्क्स
ओके दिस इज डन थ्रू राउटिंग एल्गोरिथम्स
एंड प्रोटोकॉल्स लाइक राउटिंग इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोटोकॉल या ओपन शॉर्टेस्ट पाथ फर्स्ट
एंड बीजीपी इन प्रोटोकॉल के द्वारा यह
किया जाता है राउटर्स व्हिच ऑपरेट एट द
नेटवर्क लेयर मेक डिसीजन बेस्ड ऑन द
नेटवर्क टोपोलॉजी एंड राउटिंग टेबल टू
फॉरवर्ड पैकेट अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क अभी जो
राउटिंग है वो डिसाइड की जाती है नेटवर्क
लेयर पर क्योंकि राउटिंग जो आपकी नेटवर्क
लेयर है वहां पर उसको सोर्स और डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस प्रोवाइड कर रही है ओके उसके बेस
पर क्या जो आपका जो राउटर्स है अपने राउट
टेबल में चेक करते हैं कि ओके अभी मुझे इस
पाथ के थ्रू जाना है ओके अगर किसी पास पर
ट्रैफिक है तो दूसरा पाथ चूज किया जाता है
मतलब बेस्ट पाथ टू ट्रेवल योर टारगेट मैं
आपके डेजिग्नेशन तक पहुंचने के लिए नाउ
लॉजिकल एड्रेस डिवाइस ऑन डिफरेंट नेटवर्क
मस्ट बी यूनिक आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ओके द नेटवर्क लेयर प्रोवाइड्स लॉजिकल
एड्रेसस बेसिकली आईपी एड्रेस केस ऑफ द
इंटरनेट टू डिस्टिंग विश डिवाइसेज ऑन ए
नेटवर्क ओके द आईपी एड्रेसस आर असाइन टू
डिवाइस सो दैट राउटर्स कैन यूज देम टू
डिटरमाइंड वेयर टू सेंड द
पैकेज सेल्फ
एक्सप्लेनेटरी नाउ पैकेट फॉरवर्डिंग का
काम भी किसका है नेटवर्क लेयर द नेटवर्क
लेयर इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर टेकिंग द पैकेट्स
रिसीवड फ्रॉम द ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर एंड
फॉरवर्डिंग देम टुवर्ड्स देयर डेस्टिनेशन
दिस मे इवॉल्व सेवरल राउटर और इंटरमीडिएट
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
एंड
डेस्टिनेशन ईच राउटर चेक द डेस्टिनेशन
आईपी एड्रेस एंड फॉरवर्ड द पैकेट
अकॉर्डिंग मतलब सेल्फ एक्सट की जो पैकेट्स
है आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर जो ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर से उसको पैकेट में कन्वर्ट करके उसके
बाद डेस्ट डेजिग्नेशन आईडी उस परे एड्रेस
ऐड किया जाता है उस डेजिग्नेशन के
अकॉर्डिंग उसको फॉरवर्ड किया जाता है आगे
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट राउटर के थ्रू आपके सर्वर
तक फ्रेगमेंटेशन एंड रिअसेंबली का काम भी
इधर किया जाता है इफ ए पैकेट इ टू लार्ज
टू बी ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर ए पर्टिकुलर
नेटवर्क तो द नेटवर्क लेयर कैन ब्रेक इनटू
स्मॉलर फ्रेगमेंट्स ओके नाउ अभी बात करते
एरर हैंडलिंग एंड डायग्नोस्टिक्स द
नेटवर्क लेयर प्रोवाइड बेसिक एरर हैंडलिंग
और डायग्नोस्टिक फंक्शन देती है बेसिक ओके
फॉर एग्जांपल स एमपी के थ्रू वहि ऑपरेट द
नेटवर्क लेयर एंड इज यूज्ड फॉर सेंडिंग
एरर्स मैसेजेस एंड नेटवर्क डायग्नोस्टिक्स
दीज आर द फंटी ऑफ द नेटवर्क लेयर दज आर द
लिस्ट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज्ड ऑन द नेटवर्क
लेयर आईपी आईसीएमपी ए आरपी अभी मेरे को
बोलता है सर ओ एसआई मॉडल क्यों पढ़ना
चाहिए तो आप आईईआरपी स्कूपिंग करते हो
आईपी स्कूपिंग करते हो या यह सारे काम
करते तो देखो कौन सी लेयर पर कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल काम करता है ठीक है नेट
आईजीएमपी एमपी एलएस एनडी डीएचसीपी पॉइंट
टू पॉइंट प्रोटोकॉल एलटू प एलटू टीपी ये
एक वीपीएन के लिए यूज किया जा दीज आर द
लिस्ट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल दैट आर यूज ऑन द
नेटवर्क लेयर ड्यूरिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी
जनरी सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट लेयर्स हमारे
लिए कौन सी रहेगी नेटवर्क लेयर और
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर हम फर्द जैसे ही ई मॉडल
पढ़ लेंगे उसके बाद फोकस करना स्टार्ट कर
देंगे अपने ट्रांसपोर्ट और नेटवर्क लेयर
टोटली हमारी जो जर्नी है वल साइबर
सिक्योरिटी की अभी और ट्रांसपोर्ट और
नेटवर्क लेयर से ही जुड़ी हुई है उसके बाद
हम इसी के बेस पर अटैक परफॉर्म करते हैं
इसी के बेस पर सारे काम स्टार्ट करना
स्टार्ट करते ओके तो मोस्ट फोकस करेंगे हम
ट्रांसपोर्ट नेटवर्क लेयर के बारे में
डिटेल एक्सप्लेन मैंने आपको कर दिया है
ठीक है अपकमिंग डाटा लिंक और फिजिकल लेयर
को भी एक्सप्लेन करूंगा बट जैसे जैसे
नेक्स्ट फदर सेशन आएंगे फ हम नेटवर्क लेयर
और ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के बारे में थोड़ा सा
और थोड़ा डीप जाएंगे पैकेज के बारे में
पढ़ेंगे देन उसके बाद न्यूमरेशन और
स्कैनिंग करेंगे तो दज आर आवर प्लांस नाउ
अभी बात करते हैं डेटा लिंक लेयर नेटवर्क
लिर सबको समझ में आ गई
सबका डाउट क्लियर यार देखिए प्रैक्टिकल्स
अवेलेबल है बट प्रैक्टिकल्स आई विल नॉट
एक्सप्लेन प्रैक्टिकली हम जैसे जैसे सेशन
में आगे बढ़ेंगे तो प्रैक्टिकली आपको खुद
से पता चल जाएगा जब वायस आर्क का मैं यूज
करूंगा वायस आर्क में आपको बता भी दूंगा
दिस लेयर टू लेयर थ्री लेयर लेयर फोर लेयर
फाइ व्हाट एवर मैं वहां पर आपको बता दूंगा
तो बट अभी मैं प्रैक्टिकली नहीं बताने
वाला क्योंकि नेटवर्क की क्लास नहीं है बट
क्या है कि मैं इसको कवर इसलिए कर रहा हूं
क्योंकि मेरा अपना पर्सनल मोटो आपको
समझाने के लिए एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
लेकिन जहां जहां पर जरूरत है जहां जहां
इसके प्रैक्टिकल्स आएंगे मैं इनको कंपेयर
कर दूंगा कंपेरिजन करने का मेरा काम है
मैं आपको खुद से कंपेयर कर दूंगा बट डोंट
वरी कि यहां पर आपको ऐसा नहीं लगा कि आपको
समझ में नहीं आया
नाउ डेटा लिंक लेयर डटा लिंक लेयर द सेकंड
लेयर इन द एसआई मॉडल एंड सिचुएटेड अबोव द
फिजिकल लेयर एंड बिलो द नेटवर्क लेयर ओके
इट्स प्राइमरी रिस्पांसिबल इज टू प्रोवाइड
रिलायबल कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन टू डायरेक्टली
कनेक्टेड डिवाइस ऑन ए नेटवर्क ठीक है अभी
देखो ट्रांसपोर्टेशन का काम तो
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर कर रही है नेटवर्क लेयर
क्या कर दि है एड्रेस ऐड कर रही है अभी
डली कनेक्टेड डिवाइस कौन से हैं
डायरेक्टली डिवाइस हमारा राउटर्स है जैसे
कि हम यूज कर रहे हैं मैं अपना लैपटॉप यूज
कर रहा हूं माय लैपटॉप से डायरेक्टली
कनेक्टेड क्या मेरे राउटर्स है राउटर फ
किसके थ्रू है आईएसपी तो ये क्या
डायरेक्टली कनेक्टेड है एक दूसरे चाहे वो
फिजिकल मीडियम हो चाहे वो वायरलेस मीडियम
हो लेकिन डायरेक्टली कनेक्टेड डिवाइस तो
ये है तो इनके बीच में लिंक का काम लिंक
लेयर का काम है डाटा लिंक का काम है इट्स
प्राइमरी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी इज टू प्रोवाइड
रिलायबल कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन टू डायरेक्टली
कनेक्टेड डिवाइस ऑन ए नेटवर्क
इंश्योरिटी क्शन फ्लो कंट्रोल ऑफ द डाटा द
डेटा लिंक लेयर ट्रांसफॉर्म्स रो डाटा
फ्रॉम द फिजिकल लेयर अब ये फिजिकल लेयर से
रो डाटा लेती है विच सें व्हिच सेंड्स
अनस्ट्रक्चर्ड बिट्स इनटू फ्रेम्स फ्रेम
में कन्वर्ट किया जाता है या जो आपका डाटा
नेटवर्क लेयर से आता पैकेट्स पैकेट्स को
भी किसम कन्वर्ट किया जाता है यहां पर
फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट किया जाता है एंड
स्ट्रक्चर्ड पैकेट ऑफ डाटा दैट कैन बी
ट्रांसमिटेड एंड अंडरस्टूड बाय डिवाइस ऑन
द सेम लोकल नेटवर्क और डायरेक्ट लिंक इट
आल्सो इंश्योर दैट डाटा इज ट्रांसमिटेड
एक्युरेटली एंड एफिशिएंटली ओवर द
कम्युनिकेशन मीडियम ओके बेसिकली क्या होता
है कि पैकेट्स को यहां पर फ्रेम में
कन्वर्ट किया जाता है और साथ में क्या है
कि हमारे पास पोर्ट नंबर है आईपी एड्रेस
सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस है डेस्टिनेशन आईपी
एड्रेस है अब यहां पर हमें क्या ऐड कर
दिया गया मैक एड्रेस और क्योंकि लोकल
नेटवर्क में कम्युनिकेट करने के लिए
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
होता है देखिए एक सीधा सा एग्जांपल है कि
अगर हमने किसी सिटी में किसी के पास
पार्सल भेजना तो ओके हमारे पास गांव का
विलेज का सिटी का नाम तो है हमारे पास
लेकिन पर्टिकुलर घर पर जाने के लिए हमें
क्या चाहिए हो उसका एड्रेस चाहिए उसी
तरीके से किसी पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस के अंदर
डिवाइस उसको पैकेट को भेजने के डाटा भेजने
के लिए उसका मैक एड्रेस चाहिए लोकल
नेटवर्क के अंदर
ओके हां नोट्स आपको मिलेंगे
नाउ ओके व्हाट इज
द अभी बात करते हैं फंक्शन ऑफ डेटा लिंक
फ्रेमिंग मैंने आपको बता दिया किय पैकेट्स
को फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट करता है देन एरर
डिटेक्शन एंड करेक्शन अभी यहां पर हो है
देखो वन ऑफ द मेन अभी वन ऑफ द मेन टास्क
ऑफ द डेटा लिंक लेयर इज एश्योरिंग दैट
एरर्स दैट मे बी अकर ड्यूरिंग द
ट्रांसमिशन आर डिटेक्टेड एंड कॉमन एरर्स
इंक्लूड करप्शन ऑफ डाटा ड्यू टू नॉइस और
सिग्नल डिग्रेडेशन अभी जो एरर
डिटेक्शन डिवाइस से डिवाइस के ऊपर जैसे कि
आपने फिज नेटवर्क लेयर से अगर जो डाटा आ
रहा है उसमें कोई एरर है या जो आपका
फिजिकल लेयर से जो डाटा जा रहा है ऊपर
एप्लीकेशन लेयर तक या वहां पर कोई भी
सिग्नल नॉज की वजह से या सिग्नल लॉस की
वजह से या व्हाट एवर रीजन वहां पर कोई
डाटा का करप्शन है डाटा मतलब सही से एरर
है डाटा में तोय उसको क्या करता है सेंडर
को रिट्रांसमिट करने के लिए बोलता है य
टिपिकली यूज एरर डिटेक्शन मैकेनिज्म लाइक
सीआरसी कौन सा मैकेनिज्म यूज करता है ये
एर डिटेक्ट करने के लिए सीआरसी साइक्लिक
रेडेंस चेक ए मेथड फॉर डिटेक्टिंग चेंज टू
रो डाटा कॉमनली यूज टू इंटीग्रिटी एंड
पार्टी ब ए सिंपल मेथड टू चेक वेदर डेटा
बिटस हैव बीन अल्टर्ड ओके एरर डेटाक्शन
एंड करेक्शन का भी काम करता है नाउ इफ एन
एरर इज डिटेक्टेड द डेटा लिंक लेयर मे
रिक्वेस्ट रिट्रांसमिशन ऑफ द फ्रेम और
डिस्कार्ड द करप्ट डटा डिपेंडिंग ऑन द
प्रोटोकॉल यह अभी मैंने आपको बताया था
फ्लो कंट्रोल भी करता है ना उसके
बाद मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल मैक ऐड कर देता
है आपके किसके अंदर चाहे वो इथरनेट फ्रेम
है या आपका वाईफाई फ्रेम है दोनों के अंदर
क्या करता है मैक एड्रेस ऐड कर देता है
ओके
नाउ इसको पढ़ के बताता हूं आपको द डेटा
लिंक लेयर इज आल्सो रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
मैनेजिंग हाउ डिवाइसेज एक्सेस द शेयर्ड
कम्युनिकेशन मीडियम कि जो शेयर्ड
कम्युनिकेशन जो लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क है अगर
उनमें
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट इंटरेस्ट कार्ड के ऊपर होता
है ओके नाउ मैक ड्रेसिंग वही है अभी डेटा
लिंक की दो सब लेयर्स होती है दे आर टू सब
लेयर्स ऑफ डेटा लिंक लेयर जो काम करती है
लॉजिकल लिंक कंट्रोल सब लेयर एल एलसी ओके
इसका काम क्या है द लॉजिकल लिंक सब लेयर
इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन द
डटा लिंक लेयर एंड द नेटवर्क लेयर जो
नेटवर्क लेयर है और जो डेटा लिंक क्लियर
है उसके बीच में कम्युनिकेशन का काम किसका
है एलएलसी का है इट मैनेज एरर कंट्रोल
फ्लो कंट्रोल एंड प्रोवाइड सर्विस टू द
हायर लेयर ओके इट इज आल्सो रिस्पांसिबल
फॉर
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ऐड्स कंट्रोल इंफॉर्मेशन टू द डटा फ्रेम्स
टू हेल्प द रिसीविंग डिवाइस अंडरस्टूड
टाइप ऑफ सर्विस बीइंग यूज्ड दिस ज आर द
फंक्शन ऑफ एलएलसी लॉजिकल लिंक कंट्रोल सब
लेयर नाउ बात करते हैं अभी सेकंड जो सब
लेयर है वो कौन सी आपकी
मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल सब लेयर उसका काम
क्या है द मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल सब लेयर
इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मैनेजिंग हाउ डिवाइस
ऑन ए शेयर नेट नेटवर्क शेयर्ड नेटवर्क
मीडियम एक्सेस द कम्युनिकेशन चैनल वाया
मैक एड्रेस इट डिफाइंस द प्रोटोकॉल फॉर
फ्रेमिंग एड्रेस ए मीडियम एक्सेस कंट्रोल
इट आल्सो डिटरमाइंड व्हेन ए डिवाइस कैन
सेंड ए फ्रेम इंश्योर दैट द शेयर्ड मीडियम
इज एक्सेस्ड इन ए ऑर्डिनरी मैनर टू अवॉइड
कोलिजन नाउ
बेसिकली दो सबले यूज होती है डेटा लिंक पर
मैक एक तो मैक है और दूसरी है एलएलसी ओके
तो कोई भी अगर आपको पूछता है कि डटा लिंक
लेयर के ऊपर भी कौन-कौन सी सब लेयर है तो
दो सब लेयर यूज होती है एलएलसी और मैक
नाउ लिस्ट ऑफ प्रोटोकॉल यूज ऑन
द कौन से डाटा लिंक लेयर आईपी आईसीएमपी ए
आरपी नेट राउटिंग आईजीएमपी एमसी और डीसीपी
प डटा लिक र मे
बी
सेम सेम आ गया
ओके इसके जो प्रोटोकॉल्स है मैं आपको
लिखना भूल गया प्रीवियस में बनाते वक्त
क्या आ गया प्रोटोकॉल्स चेंज करना भूल गया
ओके तो लीव इट मैं नेक्स्ट स्लाइड में
आपको बता दूंगा नाउ अभी बात करते हैं
फिजिकल र डेटा लिंक लिए सबको समझ में आया
एवरीवन क्लियर द डाटा लिंक क्लियर क्लियर
डाउट फिर भी अगर कोई डाउट है आपका तो आप
बाद में पूछ सकते हो मैंने आपको बताया कि
डाउट पूछने का तरीका क्या है हमारे इन
क्लासेस का नाउ अब फिजिकल लेयर की बात
करते हैं फिजिकल लेयर इज द लेयर वन लेयर
वन ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल फर्स्ट लेयर ऑफ द ओ
एसआई मॉडल एंड इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
एक्चुअल ट्रांसमिशन ऑफ रो डेटा बिट्स ओवर
ए फिजिकल मीडियम बिटवीन डिवाइसेज इट
डिफाइन द इलेक्ट्रिकल मैकेनिकल या
प्रोसीजरल एक्सपेक्ट रिक्वायर्ड टू
एस्टेब्लिश एंड मेंटेन फिजिकल कनेक्शन इन
ए नेटवर्क बेसिकली क्या होता है फ्रेम्स
है फ्रेम्स को बिट की फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट
किया जाता है जीरो और वन की फॉर्म में फिर
उसको क्या किया जाता है आपका फिजिकल
क्योंकि यही है यहां पर जो केबल्स आती है
जहां पर इथरनेट आती है जहां पर वाईफाई आते
हैं तो यहां पर फिजिकल कनेक्शंस है तो
यहां पर क्या है उस डाटा को फिजिकली मतलब
कि इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल की फॉर्म में या
रेडियो वेव्स की फॉर्म में या लाइट की
फॉर्म में उस डाटा को ट्रांसमिट किया जाता
है ओवर द नेटवर्क ओके इन सिंपल टर्म्स द
फिजिकल रिस्पांसिबल ट्रांसमिटिंग द बाइनरी
डाटा एज सिंगल सिग्नल्स ओवर ए मीडियम सच
एज केबल्स और
एयर अभी फंटी बात करते हैं तो ट्रांसमिशन
ऑफ रो बिट्स द प्राइमरी फंक्शन ऑफ द
फिजिकल लेयर इज टू कन्वर्ट डाटा इनटू
सिग्नल्स एंड ट कैन बी मिटेड ओवर ए फिजिकल
मीडियम दिस लेयर डज नॉट डील विद द
इंटरप्रिटेशन ऑफ द डाटा ओके फॉर एग्जांपल
इफ यू आर सेंडिंग एन ईमेल द डाटा विल
इवेंट बी ब्रोकन डाउन इनटू बिट्स एंड देन
ट्रांसमिटेड वाया इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल लाइट
पल्सेस रेडियो वेव्स जहां पर आपकी फाइबर
ऑप्टिक्स आ जाती है वायरलेस सिग्नल्स आ
जाते हैं कॉपर वायर्स आ जाते हैं दीज आर द
मोड ऑफ ट्रांसमिशन मीडियम ओके नाउ
इनकोडिंग एंड डिकोडिंग भी होती है
ट्रांसमिशन मीडियम यहां पर कौन कॉपर
केबल्स फाइबर ऑप्टिक केबल वायरलेस
ट्रांसमिशंस ओके बिट रेट कंट्रोल द फिजिकल
लेयर डिटरमाइंड द रेट एट व्हिच डाटा आर
ट्रांसमिटेड बिट रेट फिजिकल लेयर पर
डिफाइंड रहती है इट स्पेसिफाई हाउ मेनी
बिट्स पर सेकंड कैन बी ट्रांसमिटेड ओवर द
मीडियम फॉर एग्जांपल इन इथरनेट नेटवर्क द
फिजिकल लेयर मे स्पोर्ट विथ लाइक 100
एमबीबीएस 1 गगा पर सेकंड 10 गिगा पर सेकंड
डिपेंडिंग ऑन द फिजिकल मीडियन एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी यूज्ड
ओके जज आर द फंक्शन ऑफ द फिजिकल लेयर नाउ
फिजिकल टोपोलॉजी सिग्नल टाइमिंग एंड
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन दज आर द फंक्शन ऑफ द
फिजिकल लेयर एंड दज आर द लिस्ट ऑफ
प्रोटोकॉल्स इथरनेट वाईफाई ब्लूटूथ फाइबर
ऑप्टिक्स डिजिटल सब्सक्राइब लाइन डीएसएल
यूएसबी टोकन रिंग कोएक्सिल केबल एंड
इंफ्रारेड सेटेलाइट कम्युनिकेशन पावरलाइन
कम्युनिकेशन पीएलसी दज आर द एग्जांपल ऑफ
प्रोटोकॉल कुछ स्लाइड्स में मैंने क्या
किया जैसे कि लास्ट स्लाइड में ओनली
फिजिकल टोपोलॉजी के बारे में मैंने बताया
फिजिकल ट्र फंक्शनल है या सिग्नल टाइमिंग
है या सिंक्रोनाइजेशन है मैं इनका बताया
बाकी आप खुद से इसको डिटेल्स में पढ़ोगे
इन लाइंस को तो वो सेल्फ एक्सप्लेनेटरी है
मैं आपको नोट्स प्रोवाइड कर दू आप वहां से
पढ़ सकते हो तो दि आर
सेवन लेयर्स ऑफ द ओआई मॉडल कि आई होप सबको
समझ में आया होगा मैंने काफी डीप और काफी
अच्छे तरीके से एक्सप्लेन किया है सो दैट
की आपका जो बेसिक कांसेप्ट है रिलेटेड टू
एसआई मॉडल वह क्लियर हो जाए देखिए अभी एक
सवाल किसी ने पूछा था कि सर यह तो एक
रेफरेंस मॉडल है और व टीसी तो रेफरेंस
मॉडल हम क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं देखिए
टीसीपीआईपी प्रैक्टिकल मतलब इंप्लीमेंट
किया हुआ है लेकिन उसको समझने के लिए आपको
इन्हीं सातों लेयर को समझना होगा क्योंकि
मैंने आपको जब स्लाइड के थ्रू बताया था कि
टीसीपी आईपी में फाइव ले लेयर्स है जहां
पर एप्लीकेशन लेयर प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर और
सेशन लेयर तीनों के काम तो वही है और सारे
काम को क्या एज एप्लीकेशन लेयर शो किया
गया है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर आपको अलग से
दिखेगी नेटवर्क लेयर अलग से डाटा फिजिकल
लिंक लेयर आपको सारी की सारी उसके अंदर
देखने को मिलेगी जब आप ट्रैफिक कैप्चर
करोगे वाया वा सा तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा
लेकिन जब तक आपको ओ एसआई मॉडल का जो
रेफरेंस मॉडल आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा तब
तक आप प्रैक्टिकली भी नहीं समझ पाओगे
इसको मैं अपनी तरफ से कोई गारंटी नहीं दे
रहा इस चीज की हर कोई चाहे आप नेटवर्क
इंजीनियर से पूछना चाहे आप नेटवर्क पढ़ो
कहीं से भी पढ़ो आपको रेफरेंस मॉडल पढ़ाया
जाएगा उसी के बेसिस पर आपको हमेशा
टीसीपीआईपी मॉडल समझ में आता है
डायरेक्टली आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा मैंने
इतना डीप एक्सप्लेन कर दिया है कि मे बी
आप जब आप वायर शर्क पर ट्रैफिक कैप्चर
करोगे तो आप को सारी चीजें क्लियर ली समझ
में आ जाएंगी थोड़ा सा और मैं डीप
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं अभी एक रियल लाइफ
सिनेरियो के साथ ताकि आपके जो बेसिक
डाउट्स है वो क्लियर हो जाएंगे रिलेटेड टू
ओआई मॉडल देन अपकमिंग क्लासे में जब भी
अगर वायक ओपन करेंगे तो मैं आपको बता
दूंगा दिस इज द लेयर सोन सो लेयर दीज आर द
इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू सोन सो लेयर तो
डोंट
वरी नाउ
नेक्स्ट दिस वाज द ओवरव्यू ऑफ ऑल सेवन
लेयर्स नाउ वी नीड टू सी रिलेशन बिटवीन ऑल
दीज
[संगीत]
थ्री ओके थ्री नहीं ऑल दीज सेवन लेयर्स
मींस हाउ टू कंप्यूटर कम्युनिकेट विद ईच
अदर दिस माय टाइपो एरर कि देखो अभी तक
हमने ओवरव्यू देखा कि लेयर वाइज लेयर वाइज
लेकिन ये सातों की सातों लेयर एक साथ कैसे
काम करते हैं मिल उसको समझेंगे फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर किसी ने आपसे पूछ लिया चाहे
वो नेटवर्क इंजीनियर है देखिए आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में जरूर लेकिन किसी ने पूछ लि
कि ओके यार तुम यू आर गोइंग टू हैक ए
नेटवर्क बट टेल मी हाउ टू कंप्यूटर
कम्युनिकेट विद र अब दो कंप्यूटर
कम्युनिकेट कैसे करते हैं यू कांट से की
सर आई एम हैकर एंड आई कांट से कि हाउ
कंप्यूटर कम्युनिकेट ईच अदर बर वो आप पर
हसेगा क्योंकि आपको यह तो पता नहीं दो कप
दो मशीन आपस में कम्युनिकेट कैसे करते हैं
और आप उसको हैक कैसे
करोगे जब आपको
उनके इस चीज का पता ही नहीं कि वो
कम्युनिकेशन कैसे एस्टेब्लिश हो रहा है
कैसे वो ट्रांसफर करे डाटा को या कैसे
चीजें काम कर रही है तोब उस चीज को यार
खुद ही सोचिए कि इसको आप हैक कैसे करोगे
उसके बारे जोब आपको पता ही
नहीं समझ पा रहे हो कि मैं क्यों
एक्सप्लेन कर रहा हूं तो इस क्वेश्चन का
जवाब देने के लिए अगर आप किसी को
एक्सप्लेन करोगे मैंने भी किसी से सीखा था
ये ये जो लाइने है उन्हीं की लाइने मैंने
उनसे सीखा था और जब मेरे कुछ एक नेटवर्क
के सर थे उनसे ही सीखा था तो इन लाइनों
में बहुत गहरा मतलब सुपा है जब कोई भी
आपसे कोई क्वेश्चन करता है कि हाउ टू कंपर
कम्युनिकेट विद ईच अदर इवन कोई इंटरव्यू
में कहीं पर भी सिंपली आप इनको रट लो या
बोल सकते हो इनको अगर आप इसी तरीके से
एक्सप्लेन कर दोगे ना तो आपकी सारी की
सारी लेयर सेवन लेयर क्लियर हो जाएगी ऐसे
नहीं कि ये बिट वो बिट वो बताने की जरूरत
नहीं होती इन सिक्स टू सेवन लाइंस में
आपका क्वेश्चन का आंसर कैसे ईच लेयर
कंटेंस ए पीडीयू पीडीयू क्या होता है
प्रोटोकॉल डाटा यूनिट मतलब क्या है कि हर
एक लेयर पर क्या एक यूनिट काम करती है
जिसको आप बोल सकते हो यूनिट ठीक है तो हर
एक लेयर पर एक पीडीयू काम करती है
प्रोटोकॉल डाटा यूनिट ओके एंड पीडीयू आर
यूज्ड सॉरी पीडी आर यूज्ड फॉर पियर टू
पियर कांटेक्ट बिटवीन कॉरस्पॉडिंग लेयर जो
आपकी लेयर्स है ना वो पीडीयू टू पीडीयू
समझती है जो आपकी फिजिकल लेयर है वो ले म
बिट को ही समझेगी अगर आपकी डाटा लिंक लेर
तो ओनली फ्रेम को ही समझती है अगर आपकी
नेटवर्क लेर है तो वो आपकी डटा नेटवर्क
लेर पैकेट कोही समझेगी अगर आपके
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेर है तो आप सेगमेंट कोही
समझेगी समझ रहे हो कि और बाकी उसके य लेयर
बच ग अपर थ्री लेयर है वो ओनली नॉर्मल
डाटा को समझेगी समझ पा रहे हो तो पियर टू
पयर कांटेक्ट के लिए पीडी का यूज किया
जाता है डाटा इज हैंडल्ड बाय द टॉप थ्री
लेयर्स जो डाटा क्या किया जाता है टॉप
थ्री लेयर केवा हैंडल किया जाता है उसको
बाद में ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर के ऊपर सेगमेंट
किया जाता है नेटवर्क लेयर उसको पैकेट में
कन्वर्ट करती है और डाटा लिंक उसको क्या
कन्वर्ट करती है फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट करती
है ट्रांसमिशन के लिए और जो फिजिकल लेयर
क्या करती है उस फ्रेम को बिट में कन्वर्ट
करती है देन उसके बाद क्या करती है मीडिया
पर ट्रांसफर किया जाता है आपके डिवाइसेज
के थ्रू जब रिसीवर कंप्यूटर क्या करता है
रिवर्स दिस प्रोसेस ड्यूरिंग द ड्यूरिंग
यूजिंग द इंफॉर्मेशन कंटेंट इन द पीडीओ और
पीडीओ के अंदर ओनली यही इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
होती जो डाटा है उसके अंदर बहुत सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है जितनी जो सेवन लेयर्स मैंने अभी
डिटेल्स बताई है ना स्लाइड के थ्रू वो
सारी की सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
इस पूरे डाटा के अंदर होती है इस डाटा के
अंदर चाहे वो फ्रेगमेंट के थ्रू जा रहा है
चाहे वह आपका पैकेट के थ्रू जा रहा है बिट
के थ्रू जा रहा वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन डाटा
में होती है बट ये मैंने आपको मोटा मोटा
बता दिया किसी को अगर एक्सप्लेन करना हो
ओके टेक्निकल वे में
टेक्निकल वे में चलो मैं आपको थोड़ा सा
समझा देता हूं देखिए आपको अभी समझा देता
हूं डायग्राम के थ्रू कि कैसे काम करती है
चीजें आपकी सातों की सातों लेयर कैसे
कम्युनिकेट करती हैं यह आपको समझ में आ
रहा है देखो दिस इज ए पीसी वन दिस इज ए
पीसी टू बीच में दिस इ आवर होमिंग राउटर
एंड दिस इज आवर आईएसपी इंटरनेट सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर वी नो दे आर टोटल सेवन लेयर्स
वी नो दे आर टोटल सेवन लेयर दोनों के
दोनों तरफ सेवन ले अभी आपको पता है
एप्लीकेशन लेयर प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर और सेशन
लेयर पे डाटा की फॉर्म में डेटा को डील
किया जाता है नाउ जैसे ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
पे आता है तो सेगमेंट्स की फॉर्म में डाटा
को डील किया जाता है और उसके बाद यहां पर
क्या किया जाता है पोर्ट नंबर असाइन किया
जाता पोस्ट नंबर लिख दिया मैंने आई एम
सॉरी फॉर दैट पोर्ट नंबर असाइन किया जाता
है यहां पर पोर्ट किस पोर्ट पे इस डाटा को
भेजना है नाउ उसके बाद यहां पर
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर से जैसे ही नेटवर्क लेयर
पर जाता है आपका डाटा वो पैकेट की फॉर्म
में कन्वर्ट कर दिया जाता है किसकी फॉर्म
में पैकेट की फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट किया जाता
है और साथ के साथ सोर्स आईपी और
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी उसके अंदर ऐड किया जाता
है जैसे ही डटा डटा लिंक लियर के जैसे
स्विच आ गया आपके जो मॉडम्स आ गए तो वहां
पर क्या करता है कि जो आपका डाटा को पैकेट
को फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट किया जाता है जहां
पर मैक एड्रेस ऐड किया जाता है देन उसके
बाद उसको फिजिकल लेयर के ऊपर बिट में
कन्वर्ट करके जीरो वन की फॉर्म में वाय
इथरनेट केबल या वायरलेस चैनल आपका िकल
सिग्नल हुआ या रेडियो रेडियो सिग्नल हुआ
उसमें क्या किया जा ट्रांसमिट कर दिया
जाता है जैसे ही आपका फिजिकल लेयर से डाटा
निकलेगा तो नेक्स्ट कहां जाएगा आपके राउटर
के पास जाएगा नेक्स्ट कहां पर जाएगा आपके
राउटर के पास जाएगा ओके राउटर के पास जाते
क्या है देखिए राउटर के पास जाएगा तो अ
राउटर भी कनेक्टेड फिजिकली या तो वायरलेस
कनेक्टेड है या आपके किसी भी इथरनेट केबल
से तो वहां पर क्या है जीरो और वन की
फॉर्म में डटा जाएगा तो बिट्स को फिर से
क्या किया कन्वर्ट करके फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट
किया जाएगा फ्रेम में ओके या ओके दिस मैक
एड्रेस से यह डाटा आया है चलो उसके बाद
फिर से अपर लेयर पर नेटवर्क लेयर पर जाएगा
नेटवर्क लेयर पर जाने के बाद यह क्या
पैकेट की फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट किया जाएगा
किसकी फॉर्म में पैकेट की फॉर्म में
कन्वर्ट किया जाएगा अब जब पैकेट की फॉर्म
में कन्वर्ट किया जाएगा तो तो नेटवर्क
लेयर क्या है नेटवर्क लेयर पर क्या है कि
सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस और डेस्टिनेशन आईपी
एड्रेस है तो आपका जो राउटर है वो क्या
करेगा यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस उठा के देखा
ओके ये आईपी एड्रेस है ओके मुझे इस आईपी
एड्रेस प इस पैकेट को भेजना है देखिए
राउटर सिर्फ तीन लेयर तक ही समझता है
फिजिकल लेयर डटा लिंक लेयर नेटवर्क लेयर
ठीक है यह तीन ही लेयर को समझता है आपका
राउटर मैं ए3 स्विच की बात कर रहा हूं या
राउटर आ गया वो तीन ही लेयर को जानता हूं
इससे उसके बाद ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सेशन लेयर
प्रेजेंटेशन एप्लीकेशन लेयर इसको उससे कोई
मतलब नहीं ना इन चीज को जानता इनको ओपन तक
नहीं करता इनसे उससे कोई मतलब नहीं मतलब
यह सिर्फ आपके सर्वर के लिए या आपके दूसरे
नेक्स्ट सेकंड जो डिवाइस है उसके लिए है
बट राउटर इनके लिए ओनली ये तीन लेयर है तो
यहां पर जैसे इसने पैकेट को ओपन किया इसने
डेस्टिनेशन आईडी डेजिग्नेशन आईपी एड्रेस
देखा तो उसने सीधा अपनी राउटिंग टेबल की
लिस्ट निकाली राउटिंग टेबल्स में देखा तो
ओके ये इस टाइप का आईपी है तो मुझे ये रूट
लेना चाहिए तो सिंपली वो क्या करता है
नेक्स्ट अपना सोर्स आईपी डालता है राउटर
का और उसके बाद डेस्टिनेशन आईडी आईपी
एड्रेस वही रहेगा और किसके पास भेज देता
है फिर से आईएसपी के पास भेजता है आईएसपी
फिर क्या करता है पैकेट को ओपन करता है
ओके सोर्स ओके इस राउटर से आया है और इस
डेस्टिनेशन पर जाना है फिर वह अपनी
राउटिंग टेबल चेक करेगा और फिर आपके
डेस्टिनेशन पॉइंट तक आपको भेज देगा जैसे
ही डेस्टिनेशन पॉइंट पर कंप्यूटर की बात
आती है फिर से वही रिवर्स फॉर्म में पैकेट
को सेगमेंट में कन्वर्ट किया जाएगा
क्योंकि देखा होगे पोर्ट नंबर ये 80 के
लिए है क्योंकि अगर एसटीटी प रिक्वायर्ड
तो पोर्ट नंबर 80 प उसको भेजा जाएगा उसके
बाद सेशन लेयर सेशन एस्टेब्लिश करने का
काम करेगा प्रेजेंटेशन उसको क्या डाटा को
रिप्रेजेंट करेगा कि उसको इनक्रिप्ट करना
डिक्रिप्ट करना है डिक्रिप्ट करेगा उसके
बाद उसके अदर फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट करनार फम
में क एप्लीकेशन उसको यूजर के सामने शो
करेगा दिस इज द वर्किंग ऑफ योर ओवरऑल
नेटवर्क इस तरीके से सातो की सातो लेयर
आपकी काम करती है अभी मैं आपको एक
एग्जांपल के थ्रू भी समझा देता हूं एवरीवन
अभी तक सबको समझ में
आया हां यस लिंक डाटा लिंक ले र रहेगा
यस डाटा लिंक अपडेट प्रोटोकॉल अपडेट कर
दूंगा मैं डोंट
वरी अभी मैं एक और एग्जांपल समझाता हूं
फरम बिल्कुल दो एग्जांपल है एक एग्जांपल
इसमें लिखा हुआ है और एक एग्जांपल और समझा
देता हूं उसके बाद हम सेशन को एंड कर
देंगे और जो नेक्स्ट सेशन रहेगा मैं आपको
पहले बता देता हूं नेक्स्ट
सेशन हम कंपेयर करेंगे ओआई मॉडल को इन विद
साइबर सिक्योरिटी अटैक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी
के टर्म्स में ओआई मॉडल को मैं कंपेयर
करूंगा आपको बेसिक दिया अभी मैं बताऊंगा
लेयर वाइज लेयर वाइज किस टाइप के अटैक्स
आपके नॉर्मली इफेक्ट करते हैं मैं स
कंपेयर करूंगा ठीक है पूरे कोर्स में व
सारी चीज सीख भी
जाओगे जैसे कि फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने अपने ब्राउजर में जैसे य
पीसी है इस पीसी के ब्राउजर में ग कम लिया
मैंने ग क्रम में मैंने लिखा ड
example.com जैसे ही डांल क मैंने एंटर
किया तो एंटर करते ही सबसे पहले मेरी
एप्लीकेशन लेयर क्या करती है डीएनएस
प्रोटोकॉल के पास जाती है बोलती है कि
भैया देखो मुझे समझ में नहीं आया क्योंकि
देखो इंटरनेट स् को समझता नहीं डीएनएस
प्रोटोकॉल से क्या करेगी उसको उस डोमेन को
क्या करेगी रिजॉल्व करवाएगी आईपी में जैसे
ही आईपी में रिजॉल्व हो जाएगा उसके बाद वह
क्या करेगी क्योंकि एक वेब रिक्वेस्ट है
क्योंकि एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जाएगी
तोव क्या करेगी अकॉर्डिंग टू द वेबसाइट वो
क्या करेगी उसको उस प्रोटोकॉल को यूज कर
या तो एसटीटीपी यूज करेगी एचटीटीपीएस यूज
करेगी फॉर एग्जांपल अभी उसने एचटीटीपीएस
रिक्वेस्ट को चूज किया ठीक है तो
एचटीटीपीएस रिक्वेस्ट को चूज करते हु
नेक्स्ट जाएगा एप्लीकेशन लेयर ने किया
नेक्स्ट वो प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर पर गया अब
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर ने देखा हो कि
एचटीटीपीएस है मतलब सिक्योर है तो
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर क्या करेगा उधर एसएसएल
और टी एलएस यूज होता है तो उसके अकॉर्डिंग
उसके डाटा को क्या कर देगा सर्टिफिकेट्स
की इंफॉर्मेशन उन सबको क्या कर देगा उसके
थ्रू पब्लिक की के थ्रू उसको क्या करेगा
एंक्रिप्ट कर देगा उसके डाटा को एंक्रिप्ट
किया देन उसके बाद सेशन लेयर पर जाएगा अभी
फर्स्ट टाइम तो पहली रिक्वेस्ट है तो सेशन
लेयर का उसमें काम अभी है नहीं क्य सेशन
कैसे क्रिएट करेगा सेशन तो बाद में क्रिएट
होगा तो ओके देन उसके लिए फिर भी एक कुकी
ऐड कर देगा अपनी तरफ से सेशन कुकी नाउ देन
वो जाएगा ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पे ओके
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पे ये क्या करेगा ओके
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट है तो पोर्ट नंबर
एचटीटीपीएस है तो पोर्ट नंबर 443 ऐड कर
दिया सेगमेंट्स में उसको कन्वर्ट कर दिया
देन उसके बाद टीसीपी इसने चूज किया हो
क्या टीसीपी पोर्ट का यूज करना है तो यहां
पर क्या है टीसीपी अब टीसीपी क्या करता है
आपको पता है टीसीपी एक रिलायबल कनेक्शन है
क्योंकि अब यूजर को क्या चाहिए एक रिलायबल
कनेक्शन डाटा गारंटी चाहिए तो टीसीपी
पोर्ट का यूज किया है पोर्ट नंबर टीसीपी
पोर्ट 443 का यूज किया है टीसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल के कुछ गाइडलाइंस होती है कि वो
अपने थ्रीवे हैंड सेक फॉलो करेगा देन उसके
बाद ही क्या करेगा कि फर्द वो डाटा को
किया जाएगा तो अभी क्या किया नेटवर्क लेयर
प जैसे गया उसको जो नेटवर्क लेयर प क्या
फ्रेगमेंट फ्रेगमेंट सेगमेंट में तो
कन्वर्ट हो गया डाटा आपका एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट है नेटवर्क लेयर पे उसका आईपी
एड्रेस क्योंकि सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस कौन सा
है आपके पीसी का सोर्स आईपी है डेजिग्नेशन
आईडी आपके वेब सर्वर का डेजिग्नेशन आईडी
कहां से आया डीएनए सर्वर से आया देन उसके
बाद उसको फ्रेम में कन्वर्ट किया अभी मुझे
यहां पर क्या मैक एड्रेस चाहिए मैक एड्रेस
क्यों चाहिए क्योंकि मैं अपने लोकल
नेटवर्क में मैं डायरेक्टली सर्वर से तो
कम्युनिकेट नहीं कर सकता मैं डायरेक्टली
किके साथ कर स हूं मेरे राउटर के साथ
कम्युनिकेट कर सकता हूं तो उसने
डायरेक्टली क्या किया मैक एड्रेस ऐड किया
क्योंकि ये पहली रिक्वेस्ट किसके पास
जाएगी राउटर के पास जाएगी क्योंकि
ओके तो उसके बाद फिजिकल में उसको कन्वर्ट
फिजिकल में बिट में कन्वर्ट करके सीधा
राउटर के पास चला गया राउटर ने पैकेट को
ओपन किया ओके सोर्स एड्रेस ओ ये मेरे क्या
है कि लोकल नेटवर्क का आईपी एड्रेस 192168
समथिंग समथिंग और देन मेरा डेस्टिनेशन
आईडी एड्रेस है फॉर एग्जांपल 10.41 21
लाइक दैट ये आईपी एड्रेस है चलो मुझे इसके
पास भेजना है तो राउटर ने अपने राउटिंग
टेबल निकाली उसके बाद फिर आईएसपी के पास
भेज दिया आईएसपी भी ये चेक करता करता फिर
ये पहुंच जाएगा आपके सर्वर के पास फॉर
एग्जांपल ये सर्वर है सर्वर के पास
पहुंचते ही नेक्स्ट ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर आ जाती है अभी
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर यहां पर क्या है टीसीपी
443 है तो सबसे पहले क्या करेंगे ये अपना
थ्री वे हैंड सेक कंप्लीट करेंगे अपना ये
क्या करेंगे थ्री वे हैंड शेक कंप्लीट
करेंगे क्योंकि हर अरे आपको पता है
प्रोटोकॉल डिसाइड किए गए हैं ना या तो
देखो कि सवाल है लो मैं इसको क्लियर कर
देता हूं आपका डाउट क्लियर करता हूं
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर क्या है आपका टीसीपी है
तो थ्रीवे हैंडसेट
क्रिएट अ सक्सेसफुली अ मतलब कंप्लीट करेगा
थ्रीवे हैंड सेक के बाद क्या होगा फिर ये
सेशन लेयर तब तक क्या हैका जो सेशन लेयर
है सेशन ऐड कर दिया जाएगा सेशन कुकीज देन
उसके बाद प्रेजेंटेशन के पास उसको
डिक्रिप्ट किया जाएगा और एप्लीकेशन लेयर
लेयर क्या कह जो सर्वर पे जाएगी सर्वर से
क्या है कि जो भी एचटीएमएल फाइल्स होंगी
सीएसएस फाइल्स होंगी या जो भी स लेटेड
फाइल्स होंगी उनको फिर से इसी फॉर्म में
आपके जो क्लाइंट पीसी है उसके पास भेज
दिया जाएगा देन उसके बाद क्लाइंट क्या
करता है क्लाइंट
ने लॉगइन पेज मिला अब लॉगइन पेज में उसने
अपने लॉगिन डिटेल्स डालेगा जैसे तो लॉगिन
के अगेन क्या कर एक सेशन क्रिएट भी हो
जाएगा टीसीपी तो अपना एंड टू एंड कनेक्शन
बना दिया उसके बाद सेशन अपना सेशन मेंटेन
करेगा जब तक उस वेबसाइट को यूज किया जा
रहा है तो इस तरीके से आपका क्या है कि
ओआई मॉडल काम करता है रियल लाइफ सिनेरियो
में अभी किसी ने पूछा कि सर यह कैसे पता
चलागा मुझे पोर्ट 80 प भेजना है या पोर्ट
443 प भेजना है देखिए जब भी आप सबको पता
है कि पोर्ट इनके अकॉर्डिंग डिफाइन किए गए
हैं कभी आपने देखा 443 पे अगर आपका
ट्रैफिक रेयरली होगा कि 443 पे वेब सर्वर
के अलावा और कोई ट्रैफिक जाता होगा ओके
क्योंकि या वहां पर पोर्ट फोर्डिंग की गई
होगी आपके नेटवर्क में क्योंकि ये पहले से
डिफाइंड है इस को पता कि एसटीटीपी एटीटीपी
मुझे 44 443 प डिलीवर करना है एटीटीपी है
तो 4880 पे करना है आप बोलो सर किसी ने
सिक्योरिटी वजन से रीजन से उन पोर्ट को
एक्सचेंज कर दिया होगा तो वो चीज
इंफॉर्मेशन उनके पास होगी अगर उन्होंने
पोर्ट को एक्सचेंज किया होगा तो अपने जो
फायर रूल्स में में यह डिफाइन किया होगा
कि अगर ट्रैफिक 80 का आता है तो उसको कहां
पर रीडायरेक्ट करना है या 443 का है तो
उसको कहां रिड करना व सारे रूल्स डिफाइन
होंगे आपके
क्लियर नाउ उसके बाद अगर आपको ज्यादा रियल
लाइफ सिनेरियो चाहिए तो यह रियल लाइफ
एग्जांपल है कि आपको अगर कोई लेटर है किसी
के पास भेजना है तो आप उसको कंपेयर कर
सकते हो उस लेटर को लेयर वाइज किसके साथ
अपने ओआई मॉडल के साथ यह खुद से पढ़ लीजिए
अब आपके सामने स्क्रीन पर है खुद से पढ़
के आप वेरी वेल कंपेयर कर सकते विद द
हेल्प विद द ओ एसआई मॉडल तो दिस वाज द ओआई
मॉडल मेरी तरफ से ओआई मॉडल इतना ही था तो
आई विल आई गिव माय 100
कि मुझे लगता है कि शायद किसी का कोई डाउट
नहीं बचा होगा तो फर्द फिर भी किसी का कोई
डाउट है तो हम आपके नेक्स्ट 5 मिनट के लिए
चैट सेक्शन देख रहा हूं चैट में पूछ लीजिए
अगर फिर भी आपका कोई डाउट है तो आप कमेंट
सेक्शन में अपना डाउट लिख सकते हो विद योर
नेम तो ताकि जो डाउट बोर्ड है उसमें आपका
डाउट लिख लिया जाएगा और नेक्स्ट क्लास में
आपका डाउट क्लियर कर दिया
जाएगा तो अगर किसी कोई डाउट है तो प्लीज
बता दीजिए और आप लोगों सेशन कैसा लगा तो
वो भी बता दीजिए कमेंट के थ्रू कि शो दैट
की रेफरेंस मिल जाए जो लोग आज नहीं आए
जिन्होंने क्लास अटेंड नहीं की उनको पता
चल जाएग सेशन किस लेवल का था तो मुझे नहीं
लगता कि किसी को ओ एसआई मॉडल से रिलेटेड
कभी कोई डाउट
बचेगा मुझे पता है कि मुझे नहीं लगता किसी
को इस लेवल का कोई डाउट बच जाएगा ओएआई
मॉडल के रिलेटेड क्योंकि ओआई मॉडल्स में
बहुत सारे लोगों के डाउट्स होते हैं कि यह
कैसे काम करता है लेयर वाइज लेयर वाइज
उसके बाद सिनेरियो वाइज बहुत सारी वीडियो
मिल जाएगी मे भी इतना डिटेल्स नहीं होगा
उसके बाद जैसे जैसे हम आगे बढ़ेंगे तो
शायद आपको पता चल जाएगा हम कितनी डिटेल के
साथ डल करने का फायदा क्या
था ओ एसआई मॉडल एक ऐसा स्टैंडर्ड है जो हर
एक के द्वारा यूज किया जाता है हर एक
डिवाइस को क्योंकि एक डिवाइस को दूसरे
डिवाइस के साथ अगर नेटवर्क है तो
कम्युनिकेट करना है चाहे व आईओटी हो कोई
भी हो हर एक को ओआई मॉडल का फ फॉलो करना
ही करना है रेफरेंस फॉलो करना ही करना है
तो प्लीज आस्क मी योर
डाउट तो इसको खुद से पढ़
लेना मैं अभी आपके चैट सेक्शन देखता हूं
चलो किसी को कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ
सकता है
यारा
शुभम य नॉट एबल टू कांटेक्ट डीसीएसपी
कोर्स ओके हां दे वन गुड न्यूज आई लेफ्ट
फम मा माइंड कि अभी निते सर का एक कोर्स
लंच हो रहा है डीसीएसपी डिफ सर्टिफाइड
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल एक सिक्स मंथ का
डिप्लोमा ट्रेनिंग है तो आपको शायद 100%
उसको अटेंड करना चाहिए
क्योंकि व आपके लिए बहुत बेनिफिशियल होगा
बहुत सारे प्रोजेक्ट होंगे पाइथन होगा उसम
बहुत कुछ होगा ताकि क्योंकि देखो फ्री में
मैं करवा रहा हूं इधर से और उस कोर्स को
कर लोगे तो
आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने मिलेगा उसमें कोर्स
में बहुत डिटेल है तो मैं तो बोलता उसको
अटेंड करना चाहिए आपको 100% अटेंड करना
चाहिए तो बताइए किसी को कोई डाउट
है देखो नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम क्या करेंगे
कि हर एक लेयर को कंपेयर करेंगे किसके साथ
साइबर सिक्योरिटी अटैक के साथ कि फिजिकल
लेयर पर किस टाइप के अटैक होते हैं डाटा
लिंक पे या आपके नेटवर्क लेयर पे
एप्लीकेशन लेयर प किस टाइप के अटैक्स
अवेलेबल है बस मे बी हार्डली 20 या 25
मिनट में कवर हो जाए देन उसके बाद हम फिर
बढ़ेंगे आगे क्योंकि हमने पैकेट्स भी
पढ़ना है मैं आपको बताता हूं अपकमिंग
क्लास पैकेट्स भी हमें पढ़ना है टीसीपी
यूडीपी भी हमने पढ़ना है उसके बाद हम एन
मैप का यूज करेंगे क्योंकि थ्रीवे हैंड
सेक हम सीखेंगे ही कि थ्रीवे हैंड सेक
कैसे काम करता फ उसके बाद हम प्रैक्टिकली
एन मैप के थ्रू एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करेंगे टारगेट इंगेज करके उसके हर एक
मॉडल्स को यूज करेंगे स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन
को भी यूज करेंगे कैसे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करनी है कैसे पॉइंट को ध्यान में रखा जाता
कि सो ट की नेक्स्ट टाइम आप इसको यूज करने
से पहले मतलब सोचो ना कि कौन सा फ्लैग यूज
करना है कौन सा फ्लैग नहीं यूज करना पूरा
वेरी डिटेल एन मैप रहेगा मे भी एन मैप की
कुछ तीन से चार तीन क्लासेस भी हो सकती है
ए मैप के ऊपर देन उसके बाद
हम
की सर डिफाइन कहां है कस मॉडल का का भी
सभी डिवाइस उसको फॉलो करते
हैं डिफाइन यू कैन गगल
इट देखिए कितने वीडियो आएंगे मुझे लगता है
कि आप लोग बर हो चुके आप लोग डायरेक्ट
किसम इंटरेस्ट है ना कि सर डायरेक्टली हम
यह दिखाओ कि कुछ जादू हो जाए और
तो देखिए आपके जो एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग है तो मे भी काफी सेशन लगेंगे
इसमें क्योंकि आपके एन मैप को डीप कवर
करना उसके बाद हम नमरे प बढ़ेंगे एमेशन
करेंगे रेशन से कौन-कौन इंफॉर्मेशन गद कर
सकते हैं देन उसके बाद
[संगीत]
कर सकते हो कैसे इंगेज कर सकते हो सारी
आपके पास एक नॉलेज होनी चाहिए एक अप्रोच
होनी चाहिए एक स्टेप होना
चाहिए हां थोड़े से रिकन जो फर्स्ट सेक्शन
वन है उसके कुछ एक प्रैक्टिकल एक वीडियो
बची हुई है उसको मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा तो
एक बार एक्टिव रिकन कर देते हैं उसके बाद
दोनों का कॉमिनेशन में एक डीप
रिकन वो कर दूंगा सेंड कर दूंगा आपके
सामने हां यू कैन यूज वन टू कोई इशू नहीं
आप लेने की किसी भी मशीन मैन मैप को यूज
कर सकते
हो तो मैं भी आप लोगों के डाउट्स नहीं है
तो हम एक काम करते हैं अभी सेशन को एंड
करते हैं काफी लंग सेशन हो गया और आई एम
सॉरी अगर आप लोगों को मैंने बोर किया हो
तो हम सेशन को एंड कर सकते हैं
तो गुड डे
एंड चलो ओके बाय बाय गुड डे एंड सीय फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन काफी लेट हो ग कोई भी डाउट्स
है तो आप बाद में पूछ लेना ओके तो कमेंट
के सेक्शन के थ्रू आप पूछ सकते हो ओके बाय
बाय एंड गुड डे एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन